[Auto-generated transcript. Edits may have been applied for clarity.]
לא. מדובר בצעד דרסטי, אפילו סתם.
ככה. לראש.
הממשלה. שרון רק שהפעם זה לא.
תקופה. ת.
אני לא יודע איך. בהצבעה.
על. כך.
טוב. אז שלום לכולם.
היום אנחנו מתקדמים קצת על ציר הזמן ומגיעים להפתעות בעשור האחרון.
אבל לפני כן נתחיל בהקדמה ממש שחוזרת.
היסטוריה עתיקה של התחום. לפני שמתחילים רגע נפתח את הזה לפני שנתחיל?
מי מכם כאן יצא לו ללמוד על נקודות דיקור?
דמודקס? באיזה הקשר? ב.
Deep learning. עוד מלחמה כבר? פה תורת האינפורמציה.
אוקיי. בעיבוד תמונה.
אוקיי אחלה. אז אנחנו נראה היום. אז יכול להיות שחלק מהחומר?
יראה לכם מוכר, אבל כפי שאתם תראו יש לה דברים וטכניקות שאולי למדתם בהקשרים אחרים.
יש להם אינטרפטציה ומוטיבציה שקשורה למשל translation וקשורה לטקסט Generation.
אז אני חושב שאני מקווה שתמצאו בזה ערך גם מי שהכיר שאלה אחרת למי יצא ללמוד על ארכיטקטורת טרנספורמציה?
איפה אותם קורסים? כן, ממש למדתם לעומק על זה.
אוקיי, אז אתה לומד מי שלקח, מי שלא כל. יש כאן נציגות די מוגבלת לתלמידים שרשומים לקורס, אבל יש הרבה שלא לקחו Introduction to deep learning.
כל פנים, אנחנו גם נעסוק בזה היום ואתם יכולים לתת לי פידבק לגבי אם זה איטי מדי, מהיר מדי וכולי.
אבל נתחיל דווקא במשימה ולא בטכניקה במטרה שלנו.
אז צ'אנס כן. תרגום אוטומטי אז תרגום אוטומטי.
אחת המשימות הוותיקות ביותר, אולי הוותיקה ביותר, בעיבוד שפה טבעית.
ואחת הזכויות הטבעיות ביותר. סך הכל אנחנו מכירים אותה פשוט מחיי היום יום.
המטרה בגדול היא בהינתן משפט טקסט בשפה נתונה ובהינתן שפת יעד, מה שנקרא Target Language.
אנחנו צריכים לתרגם את השפה. משפת המקור.
כן, זה המושג הטכני Source Language, השפה שבה הטקסט כתוב.
לשפת המטרה Target Language, ויש הרבה וריאציות של המשימה הזאת לפעמים.
ומשונות, בכל מיני מימדים, כמובן שפות מדוברות,
אבל גם באיזה סוג של טקסט אנחנו רוצים לתרגם זה שונה לתרגם משפט מחוץ להקשר שלו לעומת פסקל לעומת ספר לעומת גם מסמך טכני כן או לא יודע,
זה נקרא לוקליזציה של אתרי אינטרנט. כן, כל הדברים האלה מערבים תרגום, אבל הם כמובן שונים במידה מסוימת מבחינת המשימה.
משימות לרוב, כשמדברים על תרגום אוטומטי מדברים על סינגל Output.
כן, אנחנו מתעניינים בתרגום אחד, למרות שכפי שאולי אתם כבר יודעים ואנחנו גם עוד מעט נראה, יש בעצם הרבה מאוד דרכים לתרגם טקסט נתון,
ויש מקרים שבהם אנחנו רוצים הרבה תרגומים, אולי באיזשהו אופן אידיאלי, אפילו איכשהו לפרוס את מרחב התרגומים, למרות שזה בעיה שהיא לא פתורה בכלל.
כן, הגרסה הקשה יותר כן, זאת אומרת הכל בסדר גמור, אבל אחד הדברים לא.
הכוונה היא המילה כן. הכוונה היא נגיד אני נגיד אני אומר לך.
לא יודע. נגיד אני אומר This מאקסלנס, נכון?
אז בעבר לפחות כשאני ככה אתה יודע דור.
דור האיקס או משהו כזה? אז כאילו תרגמנו את זה אז היינו אומרים משהו כמו זה הגיוני?
כן, אם הייתי, אבל היום אני שומע הרבה מאוד אנשים אומרים זה עושה, זה עושה לי שכל.
זה עושה היגיון. זה זה, זה תרגומים.
שניהם תרגומים ולידיים. יש ביניהם הבדל. אני לא אומר שהם לחלוטין במקום ולנטין, אבל בהחלט תרגומים.
טובים. כן, בסדר.
בעצם, כשמתחילים לחשוב על מה כרוך ולתרגם טקסט, מגלים שיש הרבה מאוד משימות שכרוכות בתוכו.
אוקיי, בעצם, כדי לתרגם בצורה טובה בין שפות, צריך על הדרך לפתור הרבה מאוד משימות אחרות שלפעמים באמת מתעסקים בהן בנפרד.
כן, אז למשל. למשל נושא של אמבטיות עם איזו שכן הפגת עמימות.
אז המילה פליי באנגלית יכולה להתאים בעברית גם למנגל וגם למשחק, למשל.
נכון? אבל משחק בעברית בהקשרים מסוימים זה גם יכול להתאים דווקא ל act נכון ולא דווקא לכלי.
כן, אז המפתח בין איזה מובנים של המילה מתורגמים, באיזה דרך?
לאיזו מילה אחרת. זאת בעיה מורכבת ולכן אומרים שבעצם כפועל יוצא של התרגום.
הרבה פעמים לא בכל מקרים, אבל הרבה פעמים אנחנו צריכים להפיג את העמימות.
כן. בעניין באנגלית.
נכון, יש הבדל בין גבוה שהכוונה שלו היא הוא בעצם כן, כמו בניין גבוה תול בילדינג לבין ציפור עף הגבוה כמו פליז.
אגב, אני הבנתי. מישהו פעם אמר לי מה ההבדל בין תול והיי.
זה משהו שקשור. אני חושב לנקודת כאילו לנקודה שאליה משווים.
נכון, אתם מכירים את זה. יש כאן דוברי אנגלית ילידים.
אוקיי, לא ניכנס לזה כאן, אבל יש איזשהו הבדל שבעברית, על כל פנים, לא נתפס, ולמעשה עד כדי כך לא נתפס שאפילו קשה לנו בדיוק.
למרות שאני מניח, כולנו יודעים אנגלית ברמה טובה בדיוק לשים את האצבע עליו.
לפעמים באמת הם מגיעות עם הזולו, שהם האלה גם הוביל לכל מיני הלצות נכון, משהו כמו הלצה ידועה שאומרת שבמערכת תרגום אוטומטי מאנגלית,
לרוסית, מרוסית לאנגלית, תרגמו את המשפט הזה מהברית החדשה שאולי אתם מכירים.
כן, משהו כמו הרוח חפצה, אבל.
לא זוכר איך תרגמו את זה לעברית. על כל פנים, כן אתם מבינים את הרעיון.
ובתרגום אנגלית רוסית אנגלית יצא הדליקו אזעקות בדמי זכויות.
כן, אז כאילו בדיוק משחק נכון? אני לא יודע אם זה באמת נכון, אבל זה משחק כאילו על הליכון, על זה שבעצם פלאש ומת.
אולי ברוסית יש כאן דוברי רוסית ילידיים.
כן פלש ומת. זה יכול להיות מתורגם לאותו מילה.
כן, וגם spirit וליקר כאילו spirit.
כמו כן. גם.
וכן, כמו שגם באנגלית לפעמים אומרים אבל לא בהקשר קל נכון?
או out of sit out of mind יכול להפוך לאם וזה על ידי התקן.
אז כאילו. Out of his mind. נכון, אבל במקרה הזה זה לא.
אוקיי וכן הלאה בסדר הזה. אני לא יודע אם זה נכון או לא, אבל רק כדי להמחיש ואנחנו גם נראה עוד בעיות.
אז בעצם בעיית התרגום, שאולי נראה שמאוד קל להגדיר אותה יחסית תמימה למראה,
בעצם מערבת בתוכה עוד כל מיני משימות שצריך להצליח בהם, ואנחנו גם עוד מעט נראה נוספות בסדר.
מה הרמה של מנועי תרגום היום?
קצת קשה להגדיר. אז מצד אחד, מה שכן אפשר לומר זה של להשיג תרגום, מה שנקרא Literary קוואליטי.
כן. זאת אומרת ממש תרגום ברמה של אנשים שזה המקצוע שלהם.
מתרגמים ספרותיים כן שזה. זה לא משהו שמכונות יודעות לעשות היום בצורה אפילו קרובה ל מתקבלת על הדעת.
כן, זה לא פשוט, לא מספיק טוב. כן, אבל אוקיי, זה מאוד מאוד גבוה.
כפי שאתם יודעים מחיי היום יום, דברים הרבה יותר יומיומיים, הרבה פעמים לכל הפחות, גם אם לפעמים יש טעויות, אפילו מצחיקות קצת.
נכון, אנחנו בטוח יכולים להבין על מה המסמך, לפעמים גם הרבה יותר מזה.
אנחנו יכולים להניח שרוב הפרטים שם, אולי אפילו הרוב המכריע של הפרטים המדויקים פה ושם.
בהחלט יכול להיות שתיפול איזה טעות מביכה, ואני לא יודע אם יצא לכם לפעמים לקרוא.
יש היום בלא מעט אתרים בעצם לוקחים כתבות מאתרים, מצטטים אותם.
כן, נגיד, אומרים זה כתבה מניו יורק טיימס, זה כתבה מ האקונומיסט וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
ואז לפעמים יש תרגום אוטומטי שלהם לא מציינים את זה.
אבל מי שככה מספיק רגיש לשפה יכול לשים לב לא מעט פעמים לכל מיני פלטות קטנות, אבל מוגשות כן.
אז כן, אז לא ברמה מושלמת, אבל בהחלט ברמה שאפשר להבין.
אפשר להבין, אפילו מצוין הרבה פעמים. כן, בייחוד כשאנחנו מדברים על נאו דומיין, על ספה של ההזדמנות, אז שם זה כבר ממש יש מערכות מאוד אמינות.
נגיד למשל יש מערכות תרגום ספציפית לתרגום פטנטים לדוגמה, נכון?
אז פטנטים אתם יודעים, בהרבה מדינות יש פרסום פטנטים.
זה יכול להיות מאוד חשוב לבדוק אם פטנט מסוים נרשם בסין או ביפן או בלא יודע כל מקום אחר.
שפה שלא הובאה, מפרסמים לא מכירים ושם הצליחו להגיע לרמה מאוד גבוהה של ממש,
משמש את החברות בהחלטות העסקיות שלהם גם בהחלטות עסקיות רגישות וכן שיש בהן סיכון גדול.
אוקיי, עוד סוג של תרגום שלפעמים מדברים עליו.
זה מה שנקרא computer עידן translation ששם זה בעצם רעיון של לתרגם, לא לגמרי להוציא את הבן אדם החוצה את המתרגם האנושי.
אבל באיזשהו פידבק כן, אולי הוא צריך לעשות איזושהי מתרגם אנושי, לעשות איזושהי בקרה על התוכן או או שאולי ייתן הצעות וכן הלאה.
וגם, כפי שאמרתי, לא רק לגבי טקסטים כפשוטם, אלא לפעמים גם לוקליזציה של Interface דוקומנטרי אה, כל מיני דברים שהם יותר טכניים.
בהחלט יש שימוש מאוד רחב. אוקיי.
אז מה בעצם כוללת בעיית התרגום? דבר אחד שדיברנו עליו באמת זה הנושא של להבין איך מתרגמים מילה במובן המסוים שבו היא מופיעה שם.
כן, בקונטקסט המסוים שבו, שבו מופיעה.
משימה אחרת שבעצם נכללת במשימת התרגום זה להבין מה הסדר הנכון של המילים נכון, אז יש כל מיני הבדלים בסדר שבהם המילים מסודרות בין שפות אחד.
אחת הקטגוריות המרכזיות שמדברים עליהם כשמדברים על שפות.
אחד מהמאפיינים דקדוקיים העיקריים זה מה שנקרא המבנה של קלוס.
המבנה של סטיב קלוזה, מבנה של פסוקית עם, הפועל באמצע הפועל בהתחלה פועל בסוף כן, אז אלה בעצם שלושת וריאנטים העיקריים,
וגם יש עוד תתי וריאנטים מסוגים שונים, אבל כן, למשל שפות שבהם הפועל בהתחלה אז ערבית ספרותית היא כזאת, וכן, גם עברית מקראית.
אגב, הרבה פעמים הפועל מופיע בהתחלה נכון, עם לפעמים ו כן שהוא לא לא ו החיבור ו אחר כן שפות S אהובי גם יש לא מעט כמו הינדי או יפנית קוריאנית.
ואסביר כמו אנגלית כמו גרמנית, SEO הכוונה שעבר באמצע בין השאר ג'ק לאו ג'ק בעברית סך הכל נוטה להיות SEO, כאילו שהפועל באמצע, אבל לא בהכרח נכון.
כאילו יש איזושהי דרגה של חופש, אבל היא לא מוחלטת.
ובהחלט יש הבדל בין להגיד לא יודע.
את ההרצאה הזאת כבר שמעתי פעמיים לבין להגיד שמעתי את ההרצאה הזאת כבר פעמיים.
יש איזשהו הבדל של רגע. את ההרצאה הזאת? כן, בדיוק.
אז יש הבדל. ניואנסים. בין הדברים. נכון באיפה שמים את המושג הזה.
אפשרי, אבל זה לטינית.
יש לה סדר מילים עוד יותר חופשי משל עברית, אפילו אם יש כאן דוברי לטינית רוסית.
אני לא זוכר איך זה בעיקר פועל בהתחלה.
או ש. באמצע כבר לא זוכר. אה אוקיי, אז היא באמצע זה.
כן. אוקיי, אז S ואז s voice כנראה זה.
אוקיי. הבדלים אחרים פרפוזיה לעומת פוסט position scan.
יש שפות, כמו למשל קוריאנית שבהם מילות יחס מגיעות אחרי כן יותר דומה נגיד למשהו כמו.
נגיד זה אולי מה שבאנגלית נגיד קצת מזכיר.
זה שמוסיפים את האור בזה של גיל נכון אומרים I'm סבנטיז years old.
כאילו מין מפתיע זה לא בדיוק, כי שם זה ממש מילת יחס כמו לבה.
כן מה וכדומה. אז זה נקרא post position אז ומסתבר שיש קשרים סטטיסטיים בין הדברים.
זאת אומרת הפרמטרים השונים שמכתיבים בדקדוק הם לא בלתי תלויים.
כן, יש קשר סטטיסטי. למשל, שפות שיש להם פועל בסוף נוטות להשתמש גם במילות יחס שנמצאות אחרי השם.
עצם כן כמו. כן. כיתה ב במקום בכיתה.
אוקיי, אז יש כל מיני קשרים ובאמת יש שם איזשהו מבנה די מורכב.
הבדל אחר שהוא הבדל דקדוקי שיכול לגרום לקשיים בתרגום.
זה מה שנקרא פודור. כן, שגם אותו יש ברוסית.
אם אני זוכר נכון. כן מה הכוונה והוא קיים גם בעברית.
אז מה הכוונה? מה הכוונה בפרוש דרופ אז pull דרופ?
הכוונה היא שאין כינויי גוף. אוקיי, אין כינויי גוף באנגלית.
זה כמעט אף פעם לא קורה. כן, זאת אומרת, צריך להוסיף שם כינויי גוף איכשהו או או.
נושא כן צריך להגיד I don't know צריך להגיד I want one.
כן, אבל בעברית בהקשרים מסוימים כן כן, למשל בזמן עבר במקרה כאן אפשר להגיד פשוט הלכתי הביתה.
למעשה אני הלכתי הביתה. יש בזה אולי איזושהי הדגשה מסוימת.
נכון, אני הלכתי הביתה.
כן ולא. משהו אחר הלכתי. זה פשוט שיקוף של אני לא הלכתי.
אוקיי, בדיוק. אז כאילו אני אומר אין קרודו. אין אין, יש פרודות.
כלומר אין פרונט נפרד שמופיע באנגלית.
הפורקן באה לידי ביטוי. אוקיי, זה נכון הרבה פעמים שפות פרודות נוטות.
זה עוד סוג של קשר בין מאפיינים. כאילו שהרבה פעמים פרו Drop נוטה להיות קורא לטיבי עם מורפולוגיה יחסית עשירה.
ולא, אבל לא בהכרח לא בהכרח. נגיד ביפנית יש גם דובר יפנית במקרה.
כן, אוקיי, לא? אז כן, שם הפלוגה שם אני מבין.
ככה ככה אני הבנתי את זה. כן, לא דובר יפנית, אבל כן יחסית.
כן, אז זה יחסית מוגבלת. יש בה דרופינג, כמו למשל כאן אנחנו רואים דוגמה שמסתבר לשאול מישהו היא אם כן, זה בעצם I don't not do like it.
כן, זה יהיה פשוט שתי מילים אחד שאומר יודע עם שלילה.
כן, עליו שזה צריך להבין מההקשר שמדובר בגוף ראשון.
כן זה לא כתוב במפורש. זה לא מוטה לגוף ראשון כמו בעברית, אלא פשוט מבינים מההקשר שאם מישהו מדבר ואומר לא לדעת או משהו כזה,
כי אף המקביל בעברית, רק שזה מילה אחת, אז זה פשוט אומר אני לא יודע כן.
ודיו like it כן. אז תשימו לב באנגלית וגם אני חושב בעברית נכון?
אם אני רוצה להגיד. זה מוצא חן בעיניך אז אני צריך להוסיף.
לא, אני לא אמת בעברית. בזה מוצא חן בעיניך? אני יכול להגיד מוצא חן בעיניך?
אז שם זהו, זה עוד עובד? כן, באנגלית אין מה לעשות, חייבים את העט הזה.
אפילו אם הוא לא אומר הוא לא יודע אם אומרים מה הוא מתייחס. חייבים לדחוף את העיט הזה.
כן, ביפנית, מסתבר, זה פשוט מילה אחת.
זה הטייה של לייק לעבר. את כל השאר מבינים פשוט מההקשר.
כן. מי אוהב את מה אוהבים?
זה הכל בהקשר. אוקיי, למה זאת בעיה?
למה זה קושי בתרגום? פוטנציאלית? אוקיי, אז מה?
אז מתי? אולי מערכת אוטומטית תתקל בקושי?
כאילו בכל זאת כל הזמן לחפש פתרונות. נגיד לתרגם מאנגלית פה ליפנית זה נראה משהו קשה במיוחד.
אתה שומע נכון, אבל כאילו אתה אתה פשוט לומד.
אתה פשוט לומד שתמיד כשיש לך או לא משנה תמיד או בהקשרים כאלה, כשיש לך כינויי גוף אתה צריך להוריד אותם.
אתה לא צריך לצייר או בדיוק נכון הפוך.
שם יהיה הקושי. כן, הפוך שם יהיה הקושי או בוא ניקח עברית ואנגלית.
כן. זכר ונקבה נכון? אני שואל.
אני שואלת בעברית באנגלית שתיהם זה Ask?
אוקיי, אני מתרגם מאנגלית. עברית.
צריך להבין. צריך להבין. אם זה מי הדובר?
אם הדובר משתנה לאורך הטקסט. זה משהו שצריך לפתור.
אוקיי. בסדר.
אוקיי, אז בוא נראה דוגמה שבה.
בעצם שנותנת קצת מוטיבציה בעצם לעשות ממש ניתוח דקדוקי כדי לתרגם.
אוקיי. איך הדבר הזה, לפחות בעבר, סייע הרבה פעמים.
למערכות תרגום. אחרי זה נדבר גם קצת. איך זה הולך היום? אז פעם הייתה חברה שקראו לה לא Scan והיא נקנתה על ידי IBM בשנות ה 80.
כן. לא משנה. אז אפשר להגיד IBM בוט לוטוס ביפנית שהיא שפה.
כן, מה שקראנו עשה וובי צריך קודם לשים את המושג ואז לשים את הפועל.
זה קל סך הכל נכון. פשוט צריך ללמוד חוק שאומר כי יש לכם עשרה ובי עץ וי או באנגלית תהפכו את אביב נכון שמה את הסדר קל, אבל בוא ניקח משפט קצת יותר מורכב.
Sources זה בית IBM בוט לאוטופיה, שזה סדר המילים.
ביפנית כמובן. זה לא יפנית, אבל זה סדר המילים של ביפנית פורס sources, יסודי, IBM, לוטוס בוט בצד.
אוקיי, כאן אתם כבר רואים שצריך ללמוד איזושהי מוטציה קצת יותר מורכבת ומשפט באורך אחר.
אולי צריך ללמוד לא פירמידת קצת אחרת, נכון, כי יש עורך אחר ואולי זה קצת מסודר אחרת.
אבל מסתבר שאם יש לכם מבנה דקדוקי, בעצם אפשר לסכם את כל ההיפר מוטציות האלה בצורה מאוד קומפקטית.
כן. אז איך זה נראה? אז זה משל זה סוג אחר של עץ מזה שאנחנו דיברנו עליו, אבל זה אותו רעיון.
כאילו זה גם איזשהו עץ תחבירי. רק בשונה מהמבנה תלויות ששם הקודקודים היו המילים של המשפט.
כאן העלים של העץ הם המילים של המשפט. ויש עוד כל מיני nodes שבעצם יוצרים את העצים מהם.
בסדר, יותר נוח לעבוד איתם פשוט בהקשרים של תחביר.
אז בגלל זה נתתי את הדוגמה ככה אז אז אם היה לנו את העץ על האנגלית כן, אז מה שהיינו צריכים ללמוד כדי להגיע לשורש.
זה יסודי. IBM לוטוס באות בצד זה ללמוד א שנוסע ואת מושב בדיקת הנושא בפועל צריכים להחליף בסדר.
ואם המוסר הוא רכיב כן או תת עץ הוא לא מילה אחת, אז עדיין הם צריכים להחליף, בסדר?
אוקיי, כלומר בצד. משהו באנגלית הופך למשהו Seed.
אוקיי, זה כלל אחד הכלל הזה. אנחנו מפעילים אותו גם כאן וגם.
איפה עוד? איפה עוד אוכלים?
מכסים את הפועל ואת השמנת. בטח כשהוא פה נכון לאותו סביבות.
כנל גם פה אנחנו צריכים להחליף. וחוץ מזה יש לנו עוד כלל אחד שאנחנו צריכים לדעת וזה שהכל פה מן טיזר.
כן, המילה הזאת שמתארת את היחס תחבירי שלו ב.
היא ביפנית מופיעה אחרי. אז כשיש לנו אמר שמשהו כן.
פרדי קאט שמשהו זה צריך להיות. משהו שבסדר עכשיו מבחינת עצם זה נורא קל.
כל מה שצריך לזכור זה כלל אחד שאומר פועל ומושא מתחלפים.
אז אם יש לכם קודקוד שיש מתחתיו פועל ומושא, תחליפו אתם בכלל אחר שאומר מילת שיעבוד ו פסוקית מתחלפים.
מילת שיעבוד אחרי הפסוקית תחליפו את הסדר. אוקיי, אז העצים הם בעצם איזומורפיזם.
רק צריך לזכור איך לסדר את הקודקודים מחדש.
אז זה כלל מאוד פשוט. למה אני מספר לכם את כל הסיפור הזה בעצם?
כדי להסביר לכם קצת מה שאנחנו תכף נדבר עליו זה בעצם למה התפתחו שיטות מבוססות תחביר לתרגום אוטומטי, בייחוד בשפות שיש ביניהן סדר מילים מאוד שונה.
אוקיי, אם נגיד כי סך הכל כן, הטקסט, התרגומים, מערכות התרגום הראשונות, כן, עוד מעט זה כן בסדר, אנחנו תכף נדבר על זה.
אבל מערכות תרגום הראשונות עבדו על אנגלית וצרפתית, ושם סדר המילים הוא סך הכל די דומה.
יש קצת הבדלים, אבל סדר המילים הוא לא דרמטית, שונה.
ואז אולי זה קצת over, כי לנתח תחבירית וללמוד כללים על עצים זה מסבך את הסיפור.
אבל אם סדר המילים מאוד שונה, זה מאוד מצמצם את בעצם מרחב האפשרויות שבו צריך ללמוד.
אם מניחים שהעצים שונים אחד מהשני רק בפער מוטציה על בנים של אותו קודקוד.
שאלות לגבי זה. הנוסחה קצת מצוננת.
אוקיי. לפעמים.
אבל ההנחה הזאת, שהתחביב התחביר מהתומכים לשאול את עצמכם אוקיי.
אז נשמע מצוין אם יש לנו שפות שהם שונות אחת מהשנייה, בסדר.
אומנם הסדר יכול להיות נורא נורא שונה, אבל אם אם היה לנו את המבנה התחבירי,
את העץ התחבירי סהכ היינו צריכים ללמוד כללים מאוד פשוטים, כאלה של איך לסדר מבנים שונים של אותו הקוד, כן של אותו הקוד.
כן, ילדים שונים של אותו הקודקוד. אבל מסתבר שזה לא תמיד תופס.
זה תופס חלק מהתופעות ואחרות לא. אז בוא נסתכל על דוגמה שבהם זה לא תופס.
נגיד למשל, הוא מצא חן בעיניי באנגלית זה יהיה עילאי.
כן כן, זה לא פשוט סדר שנכון.
אתם לא רואים את זה. זה לא שינוי של סדר המילים. מה פה התחלף גם הנושא כך בדיוק הנושא פה הוא בעצם הוא הוא והנושא בשני הוא אני כן והם ממוסה.
כן, הוא באנגלית הוא המושא, ובעברית הוא מה שנקרא כינוי שייכות על גבי איזה שהוא אידיוט.
כן, על גבי איזשהו ניב למצוא חן בעין של בעיני מישהו.
כן, אז הבדל די משמעותי.
To be cold. כן, יש כאן דוברי צרפתית בקהל.
אוקיי, דוברי צרפתית, נכון? אז שכאילו שיהיה למישהו קר זה בעצם מילולית שיהיה לו קור נכון עבורה שרואה משהו כזה נכון?
כן, וגם ספרדית זה דומה.
אם יש כאן דוברי ספרדית בקהל. שוב, ההבדל כאן הוא הבדל משמעותי בכל מקום להגיד הנושא.
נמצא שהוא מצב שמתואר על ידי תואר.
תואר על ידי Edge אקטיב. במקרה כאן יש איזשהו פועל הפועל עצמו.
לא אומר לא מחליף את ה Edge אקטיב. נכון, הוא פשוט.
שיהיה למישהו משהו כן חייב. ודווקא המוסר זה שמתאר את היחס.
והוא בכלל שם עצם. אז כאילו מבנה אחר בקוריאנית.
כן זה פשוט מה שמצאתי באיזה קורפוס די article by תומפסון תרגמו שם בקוריאנית למשהו שבעצם אומר.
חוץ מזה שסדר המילים משתנה כן, כי ארטי כן עובר לסוף כי זה כן.
הגרעין הוא בסוף בקוריאנית. גם בעצם הכניסו פה פסוקית שלא הייתה באנגלית.
זה משהו שאומר משהו כמו על כך אמרה לי תלמיד דתי שהיא דוברת קוריאנית, תלמיד דתי לשעבר,
שזה משהו כמו אל תקרא Country ביט בית כאילו bye תומפסון זה גם לא בדיוק זה כי זה בלשון אקטיבי ומשהו כמו כן מאמר.
או מאמר של. אותו תומפסון תרם או משהו כזה?
כן. בקיצור מבנה אחר.
אז הדברים האלה, מטבע הדברים, קצת יותר מורכבים מללמוד במוטציות.
ובאמת זה הוביל לקושי כשההבדל בין השפות הוא לא רק בסדר.
המילים ברמה של לשנות סדר של קודקודים בעץ, אלא במבנה יותר כן.
או הנה דוגמה אחרת שגוגל טרנסלייט עד לפני לא מעט, לא הרבה שנים, היה נכשל בה.
איך הייתם מתרגמים? נגיד למשל את היי Happened to מיקס.
דינה on campus. איך הייתם מגיבים?
במקרה? נכון, אבל באנגלית זה בעצם פועל שיצא בדיוק ככה.
Translate היה לתרגם משהו? כן כן, אני קריטי לפגוש משהו כאילו מוזר כזה.
כן, אבל. אני קראתי כן, הוא לא עשה את זה.
הוא עשה משהו לא נכון. נקראתי, אבל אז זה לא נקראתי לפגוש.
נכון זה נקראתי בדרכי. אולי כן, נכון?
כן. עוד קושי שצריך להתמודד איתו.
כן, זה מה שנקרא לקסיקון maps. כן.
מישהו אולי ראה את הסרט The Day After Tomorrow?
כן, בעברית הוא נקרא מחרתיים.
אני חושב לא. לא, הוא לא נקרא מחרתיים נכון איך הוא נקרא, אבל לתרגם סרטים הוא שלם בפני.
לא לא, אני לא מדבר על זה. אני מדבר על זה של מחרתיים עם מילה בעברית שבאנגלית צריך לתרגם ככה ספציפית.
תרגמו את הסרט הזה להיום שאחרי מחר, שלדעתי תרגום די עילג אבל לא משם.
איזה אנקדוטה. כן, אבל אין מילה אחת באנגלית ליום שאחרי מחר.
בעברית יש גם בגרמנית. כן, זה פשוט עובר מאורגן.
אה? יש דוגמאות? אה, יש את זה?
אוקיי, אז זה לא הכרתי. אז מוזר שהם לא קראו לסרט ככה.
אוקיי, עכשיו לדוגמאות קצת יותר רציניות שיבלי, איך אומרים בעברית?
לא, זה לא זה או זה אחים, אבל זה בגיוס נכון בין המחנות.
אז מסתבר שיש לזה מילה. הכניסו מילה החיים אבל אף אחד לא משתמש בה.
אוקיי, דובר הצרפתית. סליחה, מה שמך? נתן?
כן נתן. נכון? אז מה ההבדל בין סלב לריביירה?
אה, אוקיי, אז מה שאני קראתי זה שפלה.
זה נהר שזורם לאוקיינוס ורביה זה נהר שלא זורם לאוקיינוס.
אוקיי, אם הייתי עכשיו צריך לתרגם את זה לעברית והיה חשוב לי הדקות הזאת, אין מה לעשות, הייתי צריך להשתמש בכמה מילים.
נכון, הייתי צריך להגיד לא סתם כמה מילים היית הראשון, משהו פסוקית.
נהר שלא זורם אוקיינוס. כן כן, יש גם בגיאוגרפיה לדוגמה כזאת.
אז עניתי שכן. כן, אין כלי ואקסטרים.
נכון שאתה זוכר מה ההבדל? האם זה נמצא כאן בתוך הקהילות בתוך זה?
אני לא זוכר כרגע שראיתי דפוס נורא מסוים שפשוט אין לי דרך לתרגם אותה לעברית שלי, להתחיל לקרוא לזה מובלעת.
אני מקווה שאת מוציאה איזה משהו. כן כן בדיוק.
ויש כל מיני כאלה. העצה שלי לריי בגרמנית זה זה לעזוב מסעדה מבלי לשלם את החשבון.
אין את זה בעברית. אני לא מכיר מושג באנגלית. יש דין אנד דה שדומה לזה, אבל זה גם לא מנה אחת.
וכן הלאה. הסופר הידוע ולדימיר נבוקוב כתב קטע מפורסם אני לא יודע אם הוא נכון.
ואני אקריא לכם אותו כי הוא נחמד. Now single no single וורדים, English וונדררס old Shade זו טוסקה.
אני אגיד את זה נכון. טוסקה משהו כזה. דווקא טוסקה?
אוקיי. תשקף את הצדק. פסד מאופיין Fault.
איתי זה Sensation Grace spirit של English. אופן מודעות Miss Pacific cos.
אטלס mobile לבוא איתי זה delta code so long.
את Nothing to look for. השיק פאנינג, אבי Guild וסלבס נאס.
מנטור Through young in particular קייס אטמי ביד את Desire for somebody of something specific.
נוסטלגיה. אה? נראה לי זה אמור להיות or something specific.
נוסטלגיה ליפסטיק nest. אדל לא סלב? Grade into and white border.
אוקיי, אז בקיצור, הוא ניסה להסביר למה הוא לא יכול לתרגם את המילה הזאת מרוסית לאנגלית.
אוקיי ו. בין אם הוא צודק ובין אם לא קטונתי.
אבל על כל פנים, זה בהחלט משהו שיש לו תיעוד נרחב.
טוב. אז מה עושים כדי להתמודד עם כל שלל הבעיות האלה בתרגום עם זה שבעצם זה בעיה כל כך קשה שמערבת כל כך הרבה דברים, הבנה סמנטית עדינה,
הבנה של מובנים, של מילים, התגברות על טקסט, על אפס התגברות על מבנים תחביריים וסימנים אחרים, פרי מינג שונה וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
בגדול, אפשר לשים את הגישות השונות שהשתמשו בהם לתרגום.
על משולש כן קרוי על שם מישהו בשם וו קואן, שבגדול אומר ככה צלע אחת של המשולש הזה זה בעצם שפת המקור.
אוקיי, והצלע השנייה היא שפת המטרה.
עכשיו אתם יכולים לתרגם מילים למילים מסטיקים ל string.
אוקיי, זו הגישה הבסיסית ביותר. פשוט אומרת יש לי מחרוזת בשפה אחת, יש לי מחרוזת בשפה אחרת.
אני עכשיו צריך להבין איך זה קורה, להשמיט מילים, להוסיף מילים, לעשות, להבין וואטאבר.
אבל זה הכל נמצא בתוך המכונה, בתוך הקופסה.
אני יכול גם לנקוט בדרך אחרת. אני יכול למשל לנתח ניתוח על ידי עץ.
כן על ידי תחבירי, ניתוח תחבירי ואז לתרגם את זה לעץ בשפה השנייה כמו שראינו באיזה מקרה דוגמה.
אנגלית ויפנית. לפעמים זה רעיון טוב. זה נקרא סינטה, סטייק transfer.
לפעמים זה לא רמה מספיק טובה. נכון, בגלל שעשינו טקס הוא גם שונה בין השפות ולא רק על ידי פר מוטציות.
גם זה ראינו דוגמאות כמו. נכון כמו הדוגמה בקוריאנית, הוא מוצא חן לעומת לייק או כל מיני דברים כאלה.
אז אומרים אוקיי, אפשר לעלות לרמה עוד יותר אבסטרקטית שבה אני מתאר את המשפט באיזשהו מבנה סמנטי שהוא לא רגיש בדיוק להאם הפרה דיקט.
האם היחס הזה מובא על ידי אידיוט כזה עם כינוי שייכות כמו מוצא חן בעיני איקס או על ידי פועל או על ידי כל דבר אחר?
כן, יש לי נכון בעברית זה i have באנגלית ולא משנה ובערבית זה גם עובד אחרת.
וכל הדברים האלה יתורגמו לרמה קצת יותר אבסטרקטית שהקצה שלנו זה מה שנקרא אינטר לינגואלי.
כן, מה זה אינטר אינטרנט? מה זה ממש שפת ביניים.
כן, לפחות באידיאל של אינטר לנגוע. אין כמעט מערכות שעושות באמת אין קרלינג כי אף אחד לא בדיוק יודע איך היא נראית,
אבל לפחות באידיאל של אינטר לינגואלי זה שפה שהיא כל כך אבסטרקטית, שכבר איבדנו כל מאפיין ספציפי של השפה שממנה התחלנו.
אוקיי, עבדנו למשהו שהוא באמת משותף לכל השפות וממנו אפשר לתרגם לשפת היעד.
אוקיי, זה לפחות באידיאל. אנחנו זמינים כל הזמן.
לא הספקתי להעביר את הספר. לא, לא בטוח.
יכול להיות שאתה. אתה יכול לחשוב על זה שהאינטרנט הוא היא הרבה יותר עשירה מכל.
יותר עשירה מכל אחת מהשפות. אז נגיד אם בעברית יש הבחנה בין זכר לנקבה באזכור בגוף ראשון ובצרפתית יש הבדל בין נהרות שזורמים לאוקיינוס ולא ובין.
אני לא יודע, אבל בקוריאנית אני לא מספיק לי להגיד של.
אני צריך להוסיף גם פועל שאומר שהוא מה הוא עשה עם הדבר שהוא שלא.
כמו כן article by תומפסון וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
אז האינטר לינק הוא המכיל את כל המידע הזה, ואז כל מה שנותר זה לתרגם ממנו לכל שפה על ידי בעצם הטלה, על ידי איזשהו Logic production כזה.
עכשיו זה אולי אידיאל מעניין. הוא בהחלט מאוד מעניין תיאורטית לחשוב עליו.
האם זה בכלל אפשרי ומה המגבלות של זה?
הייתי אומר שהוא יותר אידיאלי.
זה יותר מין סוג של אסימפטוטית, כאילו אתם יכולים לעלות מדרגת אבסטרקטיות ואיכשהו, אבל זה פחות או יותר המקרים היחידים שבהם ראיתי את זה קורה.
זה באמת שיש לכם שפה מאוד מוגבלת, שהיא בדרך כלל גם מאוד טכנית.
כן, נגיד, אתם רוצים לדווח דיווחי מזג אוויר? אוקיי, אז יש לכם קריאות של תחנת רוטנברג?
קוראים לזה הפודקאסט Station. כן, תחנת החיזוי.
וכתוב שם לחות ומשקעים וטמפרטורה וטסלה טה טה טה טה טה.
ולא מעניין אתכם שום דבר אחר לגבי הטקסט. אז עכשיו אתם יכולים לקחת את התחזית שכתבתם בשפה אחת, לתרגם אותה לטבלה הזאת, נכון?
ולכתוב אותה בשפה אחרת ובאמת אין בעיה לעשות את זה.
כן, כל עוד השפה שלכם מאוד מוגבלת. ואם אנחנו מדברים על שפה פחות טכנית ויותר אינטנסיבית אז זה לא יעבוד.
השאלה. טוב.
אז הגישה הראשונה שהשתמשו בה. ובעצם אחרי שעשו לופ גדול דרך כל מיני תחנות.
אני ככה הקדים את המאוחר. גם חזרו אליה בסוף היום, אבל כרגע נתחיל מהשטות עם הגישה יותר קלאסית.
זה בעצם direct approach. כן די transfer, כלומר, כלומר לתרגם מחרוזת למחרוזת.
איך עושים את זה? שוב בגישה הקלאסית כן, בגישה הקלאסית אני מדבר גישה קלאסית סטטיסטית כן.
אז אולי לתת לכם קצת ציוני זמן פה?
תרגום מכונה. זה תחום שעסקו בו מראשית ימי המחשב הדיגיטלי.
תחילת שנות ה 50 כבר הייתה ממש עבודה. פרויקטים רשמיים עליו היה אפילו מישהו ב MIT מישהו ישראלי, אפילו כזה.
פרופסור באוניברסיטה העברית, יהושע בר הלל, שעבד על זה מסגרת אקדמית.
בקיצור, תחום מאוד ותיק.
הגישה סטטיסטית הרבה זמן לא, לא ממש עבדה.
כן, היה צריך. זה סך הכל גישה די כבדה, בטח ביחס למכונות שהיו קיימות אז.
השתמשו יותר בגישות. שמרו על Basic. IBM פיתחה את מנועי תרגום הראשונים הסטטיסטיים שמבוססים על למידה קורפוסים.
היא פיתחה את הגישה הראשונה שבאמת עבדה והתחילו עם אנגלית צרפתית.
אנחנו מדברים על תחילת שנות ה 90 ומאז המשיך ב כן, כל מיני דרכים, אבל בקיצור על ציר הזמן אנחנו בתחילת שנות ה 90.
אז מה הרעיון? הרעיון הוא סך הכל די פשוט אנחנו לוקחים.
אנחנו רוצים לתרגם משפט מ במקרה כאן עברית למסך במקרה כאן מאנגלית.
ל. עברית או ספרדית או נגיד עברית וספרדית.
זה הדוגמאות שמובאות כאן. מה אנחנו עושים? דבר ראשון אנחנו הולכים ועושים בעצם למתי זה עצירה של המשפט.
הופכים את הכל ללמוד אבל לא שוכחים את ההטיות אלא גם את ההטיות הופכים לפיצ'ר.
כן, אז למשל Mary Don't Sleep, אנחנו הופכים את הדלת לדו בהטיית זמן עבר ואחרי זה נוט כן מפרידים קטנות, הופכים לדו בהטיית זמן עבר וכן הלאה.
אז מקודדים את זה יותר בבירור. אם יש לי עברית אז שם גם יש לי קצת יותר מורפולוגיה.
אז את הירוקה אני יכול להחליף? הירוק בהטיית נקבה ואצטרך להחליף סטר והטיית זמן עבר נקבה וכן הלאה.
אוקיי, אז זה בערך הרעיון לעשות איזשהו ניתוח מורפולוגי.
אחרי זה אנחנו נתרגם את המילים אוקיי, יהיה לנו איזה שהיא טבלה.
שאנחנו אולי יש בה טבלה כמה אפשרויות ונצטרך להשקיע קצת יותר מאמץ, אבל בגדול ננסה לכל מילה.
למצוא את המילה המתאימה ביותר עבורה בתוך ההקשר.
אידיאלית, למרות שהיכולות אז להכניס הקשר בחשבון היו הרבה יותר מוגבלות.
כן, בעיקר language. מודלינג כזה של מרקוב מודל כן, אין גם אימוץ מודלים.
ואז למשל, אם אנחנו מתרגמים לספרדית, אז כן, מרי טוב בדוגמה כאן הפך למריה נגיד ובנות הפך נאו ועדו לגמרי נשמעת, וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
אז כל אחד מהם אנחנו נחליף. לפעמים אנחנו נחליף מילה לכמה מילים כן, כי לתת יש כאן דוברי ספרדית בקהל.
אוקיי, כי בספרדית מסתבר לסטור זה בעצם לתת סתירה.
כן, אז צריך להחליף כמה מילים.
בעצם במקום סלק זה פה הפך לדר שזה ב ט באטריות זמן עבר כתוב עונה בפתח שזה סטירה.
כן איזה. אה כן לוורד זה ברוך שזה מכשפה ירוקה.
אחרי זה הדוגמא לא שלי. אגב, אם אתם תוהים איפה נמצאת הדוגמה הזאת מצאתי אותה באיזה מצגת.
אז אחרי זה אנחנו צריכים לסדר מחדש את המילים. כמובן שאם סדר המילים הוא מאוד שונה, כנראה לא נצליח ללמוד את זה בצורה אפקטיבית.
אבל אם זה רק שינויים קלים כמו עם אנגלית וספרדית יש סיכוי.
כן, אז הנוט אמור להיות לפני בספרדית?
כן וגרין וויט שופך צריך בעצם להפוך לפרו חבר ולא עובר.
The בוכה כן, הסדר של אג, כתיבה מתחלפים ואז אנחנו מחזירים.
אנחנו מטים את המילה לפי ההטייה הנכונה שלה. כן, אז את דר לתת בעתיד זמן עבר הופכים לדיו שזה אומר שזה ההטייה הנכונה של הטקסט.
אז זה בערך הרעיון, זה הגישה הקלאסית, וכאמור היא הצליחה לתת כאילו צריך באמת לעבוד.
לא בצורה מושלמת. אבל אם השפות היו יחסית דומות אחת לשנייה, נצליח לעבוד בצורה מתקבלת על הדעת.
אחרי זה אנחנו רואים משהו כמו עשור אחרי זה תחילת שנות האלפיים כניסה יותר מסיבית של הסינטטי Transfer.
כן, מה שאמרנו קודם שלומדים כללים, נאם פרייס מורכב מאד ונאום באנגלית הופך בספרדית.
לנעם פרייס מורכב מנער ועד ז'קטים, וכנל מה שראינו ביפנית.
ובעצם השיטות, התחביר איות די התגבשו בתור השיטות המרכזיות.
לפחות במקרה של תרגום בין שפות. לאט לאט כבש יותר ויותר זוגות שפות, עד בערך אמצע העשור שעבר, שאז בעצם עברנו לגישות אחרות שתכף נדבר עליהם.
בגדול, הצורה שבה הדברים האלה נלמדו. אני לא אכנס פה בגלל שזה טכנולוגיה שהיום כבר נחשבת מאוד מיושנת.
אנחנו לא ממש ניכנס לה אלגוריתמיקה, אבל נראה ככה.
אגיד בגדול שהגישה בעצם הגישה הכללית הסתמכה על מה שנקרא על כופרה.
כן, שזה אתם זוכרים למעשה, אולי מהשיעור הראשון קורפוסים מקבילים.
בגדול זוכר? אוקיי, מה זה כשבמשך כמה?
השם. שאפשר גם להשתמש עבר את השפיץ.
אם כן, הרעיון שיש לך טקסט ותרגום מאוד כמה שיותר מילולי או נאמן בשפה.
בשפה אחרת וממש רצים אחד ליד השני. בדרך כלל הם מיושרים.
כן, הם לא בהכרח מיושרים לגמרי, זאת אומרת, אבל פחות או יותר כן, זאת אומרת, זה לאו דווקא שיהיה משפט מול משפט.
לפעמים משפטים מתפצלים, לפעמים משפטים מתאחדים, אז צריך לעשות איזשהו פרי Processing כדי להפריד את זה לרמה של משפט מול משפט,
אבל זה מספיק קרוב כדי שיהיה אפשר לעשות את זה בגישה סטטיסטית באופן סביר זה נקרא contain
סלעים מנט ואז הסימון אליין מנט וכל הדברים האלה יש מגבלות אבל מצליחים לקבל סיגנל לא רע.
זה הקורפוסים הראשונים שהשתמשו בהם היו קורפוסים בעצם של רשומת הפרלמנט הקנדית, שהם מתונות גם באנגלית וגם בצרפתית,
עד שאנחנו צריכים לצאת להפסקה גם באנגלית וגם בצרפתית, שפשוט שם התרגומים הם סך הכל מאוד מילוליים, וזה גם היה data פתוח שאפשר להשתמש בו.
בהמשך נכנס גם הקורפוס של האיחוד האירופי, שהוא הרבה יותר עשיר.
יש שם איזה 24 שפות שונות שכל טקסט מתורגם אליו.
כל מסמך, כל דיון רשמי בפרלמנט האירופי צריך להיות מתורגם לכל השפות האלה,
אז זה כבר נתן הרבה יותר זוגות שפות, וכיום יש כבר אוסף הרבה יותר נרחב של קורפוסים, שרבים מהם מפורסמים.
במסגרת כנס שנתי לתרגום מכונה שנקרא Twenty צנחנים.
שכר טוב, אז בואו נצא לרבע שעה הפסקה בחסות.
אני חושבת שקשה למצוא ברשת החברתית של בית המשפט.
אז. כאילו מה שתיארת פה אז אני חושבת ככה מושכלת אבל לא בטוחה ככה.
כן? אז באופן עקרוני כן. אז באיזה טכניקה אתה משתמש?
אבל בוא נגיד להחליף מילה לרצף.
למה זה חדש? דיברנו על הצמח עוד כמה מילים בתחילת שנות ה 21 ואין מה לעשות עכשיו דיברתי איתן ברשת כללית.
אפילו לא דיברתי בדיוק על החוויות שלנו ברשת, אבל זה הכל.
אם אתה ממש מדבר על הספרים של בית המשפט, כנראה שזה קשה להם לפרסם ספר.
אבל אם זה ברמה של אחד הספרים של מחלקה מצויינת בסוף באיזה סרט סרט אפשר?
היה אפילו רוצה. להשתמש?
איך אנחנו יודעים שאנחנו פה? שאלה נוספת אבל.
עכשיו. אותך? בעצב.
תבין, אתה צריך על הדרך לפתור לא מעט. למשל מתוך אלף קולות.
כן, יש להתרשל ולרצות את קולות הדוח, למשל במידה של הבדלים בסדר הרגיל, כאילו הבדלים של מובנים מדעיים בשתי שפות מוגבל לסך של גילה אחרת.
אז בעצם שהחלק בעיות שבדרך הוא חייב לחזור על הדרך.
צריך להבין שגם אצל חלקם כתבתי פה איזה חוסר.
מצאתי. אף אחד.
כל. כך.
חקירת רצח. לתמוך.
אז ככה. צניחה חופשית.
לעומת זאת. ת.
ת. ת.
ת. ת. אוקיי, נמשיך.
בסדר, אז כשמתחילים לחשוב על הבעיה הזאת בצורה סטטיסטית בעצם.
אחד הדברים הראשונים שצריכים לעשות. כפי שציינתי בסוף השיעור הקודם זה בעצם לקחת את Parallel קורפוס.
נקראת את הקורפוס המקביל, שבו יש טקסטים בשתי שפות שעוקבים אחד אחרי השני ולנסות לעשות write line.
כן, בעצם לנסות איכשהו להתאים ברמת המילים. עכשיו ברור שהוא עוד אלמנט.
הוא בהגדרתו לא יכול להיות מושלם, כי ראינו חלק מהמילים כשעוברים לשפה אחרת הם בכלל השמטות.
לפעמים. מילה מסוימת מוחלפת בכלל בביטוי שיש לו מבנה אחר.
יש כל מיני דברים שעשוי לקרות, אבל בהרבה מקרים, אפילו בשפות שונות אחת מהשנייה,
בהחלט אפשר להתאים בין מילים, וזה מאפשר לנו ללמוד מידע סטטיסטי רב ערך לגבי איזה מילים בעצם?
מהו סט המילים שלהם? מילה בשפה נתונה היא יכולה להיות מתורגמת וללמוד אולי באיזה הקשר.
כל אחת מהאפשרויות היא רלוונטית. אז נגיד, למשל, אם ניקח את הדוגמה הקודמת של מדינת Sleep Green Watch ומריח תנועת דיור בפתח הלב,
רוחבה ירדה, אז מה שאנחנו רואים זה שאוקיי מרי מתורגם למריה ואת Didnt מתורגם לנו.
בעצם, למרות שזה לא תרגום מדויק, אבל פחות או יותר זה הדבר היחידי שנשאר וזה sleep מתורגם לשלוש מילים לפחות כפי שאתם רואים, יש שם מילת האז.
זו מילת יחס אוקיי, שהיא מופיעה בספרדית אבל באנגלית, לא באנגלית.
לסתור זה לסתור את מישהו נכון, בעצם לא בלי מילת יחס ואז זה קצת שאלה שרירותית.
האם רוצים להגיד שאז זאת פשוט מילה שלא מותאמת לשום דבר להגיד?
אולי זה חלק מהזה?
אולי עלה אולי להגיד שזה חלק מהסלט כמו כאן באמת אין לזה כל כך תשובה אחת.
זה קצת תלוי בסכמה שמשתמשים בה. אבל לגבי חלק מהמילים, סך הכל יש תשובה מאוד ברורה.
נכון, Watch זה פשוט רוחה וורד זה פשוט crime וכן הלאה.
וזה בעצם אחד מהכלים הבסיסיים של משימות and Station,
והוא היה שלב טריפ קרוסינג טריפ Processing הכרחי עבור הגישות הסטטיסטיות היותר מוקדמות היום הוא איכשהו נבלע בתוך המערכות,
כפי שאנחנו עוד מעט נראה כדי לבצע תרגום מבוסס תחביר.
כן, נשים translation. אז כן, זה בגדול דיברנו על זה בעל פה, אז כאן מה שהיינו, מה שהיו עושים זה פשוט לוקחים את הקורפוס ה מקבילי שרוב מפרסם זרים.
בעצם כן עושים ניתוח תחבירי של שני הצדדים.
זאת אומרת, לוקחים פר סה עבור אנגלית לוקחים פלסטר עבור סינית,
במקרה הזה בונים לכל אחד מהם עץ בנפרד ואז מנסים ללמוד כללים על איך העצים משתנים כשעוברים בין שפות.
כן, אז כן, Northwind האוז ודה וויקנד.
אז כן, בעצם. היו רואים שמבחינת המבנה התחבירי כן, זה הכוונה, לא פסוקית Northwind.
House זה פשוט תרגום. כן, זה נאו פרייז בסינית שאומר The Storm Northwind, אבל בעצם שהוא ווינד הוא הגרעין.
כן, הוא עליון שהוא הגרעין. האורז הוא זה הוא בעצם במקרה כאן H אקטיב בכלל.
אז אין לו כנראה בדיוק תרגום לאנגלית כתואר. אז בגלל זה כן.
בגלל זה כתוב כאן הגלוס כאילו זה כאילו זה פועל.
אז היו צריכים באמת ללמוד את כל ההבדלים האלה. מה מתרגם למה?
ובאיזה הקשר הסדר משתנה ואיזה יחידה תחבירית הופכת לאיזה יחידת תחבירית.
אבל הרעיון הוא סך הכל דומה, רק שזה דורש Try Processing נוסף מעבר ל write line, שהוא בנייה של העצים ובעצם Thriller אלמנט שעליו נלמדים החוקים.
כן, וזה היה הדוגמה שאמרתי קודם קרה לפגוש את הבחור אתמול זה תרגום באמת מלפני כבר כמה שנים, לא המון שנים כזה.
אולי חמש שש מגוגל Translate. בסדר.
וכל ההקדמה הזאת כדי להביא אותנו לימינו, אלו שבהם כבר לא עובדים באותן שיטות קלאסיות שהזכרתי עכשיו, שבהן לומדים ממש מוטציה.
הוספת המוטציות על סדר המילים וכן הלאה. אלא עובדים כמו בהרבה מקרים בין על פי דרך רשתות נוירונים.
אבל כפי שאנחנו נראה,
חלק מהעקרונות חלק מהסיבה שבנו את הארכיטקטורה כמו שבנו אותה בעצם מבוססת על אינטואיציות שהגיעו מתוך מתוך העבודה בתרגום העבודה של תרגום סטטיסטי.
לא נורא, ענה לי כן, וזאת נקודה חשובה. נגיד, למשל יאיר וייס.
אני לא יודע אם אתם לקחתם קורס פה. חבר סגל כן, חבר סגל במחלקה שהוא בעצם מגיע מתחום הביזנס.
כן, מתחום הקומבינות, ואני זוכר שדיברתי איתו, אני חושב אחרי שפעם ראשונה הוא שמע ויקרא על הטרנספורמר, אז הוא אמר.
הוא אמר כן, עבודה באמת מאוד מעניינת, אבל אני לא מבין למה אומרים שה Transformer כן.
שעכשיו כבר לא צריך בכלל לדעת שום דבר על שפה, כי פשוט יש את הטרנספורמר.
כן, שהוא לומד את הכל בלי שיש בו שום דבר שקשור ספציפית לשפה בתוכו.
הוא אמר כאילו מאוד רואים איך הארכיטקטורה הזאת בעצם נולדה, מתוך תובנות שהיו כן שהושגו לגבי איך עובדת שפה,
איך עובד מנוע, תרגום ובעצם זה מאוד מבוסס על רעיונות כאלה.
אז שוב, זה עניין קצת של אתה עדיין לא.
לא יודע. זו הייתה התרשמות שלו, אבל כפי שאנחנו נראה, בהחלט יש כאן.
יש כאן כל מיני תובנות הנחות משמעותיות שכן השתמשו בהם.
טוב, אז מה היה מה? אז הפגישה הראשונה שבעצם או הגישה הכללית?
כן, הראשונה שנלמד בהקשר הזה זה בעצם הגישה שנקראת Encore או Recorder שאני חושב שאמרתם את זה רובכם שנתקלתם בה בעבר,
אבל אני אגיד אותה מאוד בקצרה הרעיון בין קודר Discover Model זה שלרשת המתרגמת יש בעצם שתי קומפוננטות קומפוננטה אחת מקבלת את משפט המקור.
כן, זה נקרא code, והמטרה שלה היא בעצם לייצר וקטור או אוסף של וקטורים שהם איזשהו סוג של קידוד כן מכילים את המידע הרלוונטי ממשפט המקור.
אוקיי, זה התפקיד של האינקובטור וזהו. זאת אומרת output שלהם codes הוא בעצם איזה שהם וקטורים.
כן, איזשהו הם בדיוק בעצם של המשפט או אוסף שנים של המשפט הדי קודר.
מה שהוא עושה זה בעצם זה מודול אחר ברשת שהוא מצד אחד ניזון There ומצד שני הוא ניזון מהפרי FX שכבר אנחנו מניחים יוצרת.
כן, זה עובד כמו מודל שפה. כל פעם יש לנו פשוט התפלגות על פני התוכן הבא.
והמילה הבאה. מה שעדי קולטר עושה פה בירוק זה מקבל את האאוטפיט שלהם Order ומקבל את הפרי פיקס ויוצר בעצם התפלגות על פני המילה הבאה.
אז איך זה נראה במקרה? כאן הצגתי בעצם את אחד מהם, קראודר, דיק הרדר נטוורקס.
הארכיטקטורה אולי הכי הכי ראשונה ובסיסית.
אז יש לנו נגיד תרגום מאנגלית, מגרמנית, סליחה לאנגלית.
אז איך אנחנו חושבים עליו? אנחנו בעצם בונים איזה שהוא ארנק.
כן, במקרה כאן זה בעצם Stack Turning. כן, זה. דיברנו גם קצת על זה.
באיזשהו שלב הזכרתי בקצרה זה הרנין שהעידן site שלו בעצם מזינים נוסף שאולי מזינים עוד הרנין נוסף וכן הלאה.
אבל בגדול זה פשוט RNA.
אם כן, אין זה הרנין שמה שהוא עשה זה הוא פשוט עובר על המשפט משמאל לימין ונקודות אותו כן בולע או מזינים, מזינים אליו מילה אחרי מילה.
פונקציה רקורסיבית לוקחת את המילה הזאת ואת נגיד סטייט של השלב הקודם ומייצרת מעין עידן Hidden State של המצב הנוכחי.
אפשר לחשוב בעצם הלהיט סטייט האחרון כן, כלומר הזה של התוכן האחרון שלה End of Time באינטרנט.
כן, בסוף Intense שאחשוב עליו כאיזשהו ייצוג של המשפט.
נכון, כי הוא מבוסס בעצם כל התוכן הזה שהיו עד אותה נקודה.
ועכשיו אפשר לבנות בעצם מודל שפה שהוא בעצם זהה למודל השפה הארמני שדיברנו עליו לפני כמה שיעורים.
בשינוי אחד הוא מקבל כאן input גם את Encore, את מה שאין יותר פלט.
כן, אולי רק את הווקטור האחרון. אולי מכל שכבה הוא מעביר את העידן סטייט כמו כאן.
לא נורא משנה. הנקודה היא שהוא מקבל עוד איזשהו בנוסף.
לכן לפונקציה הביקורתית הרגילה שמקבלת פשוט את הפרי פיקס, שהמשפט ואת צריכה לתת התפלגות על פני המילה הבאה.
הוא מקבל גם את העין Corning שיעקוב אחר פלט, וזה מה שאמור לאפשר לו בעצם לפלוט משפט שהוא לא סתם משפט סביר באנגלית,
אלא באמת זה שהוא תרגום של משפט בשפת המקור.
אוקיי, אז בסך הכל זה ארכיטקטורה מאוד דומה לארכיטקטורה של הנוירו Language Model של Harman language.
בגלל שראינו. חוץ מזה שיש פה עוד איזה RNA נוסף באדום וכחול, כן שעובר על המשפט מייצר וקטור או וקטורים,
שבאיזשהו מובן מייצגים את המשפט שהערכים שלהם הם פונקציה של כל התוכן במשפט המקור ובעצם ה Remote הירוק.
קלמנוביץ עדיין יכול להתבסס על אותם אפקט.
בסדר. שאלות לגבי זה כן יכול לחשוף.
כן. אז אולי קודם ניזכר מה זה hMobile?
אוקיי, זה בעצם מה שמופיע פה בירוק. אבל על מה דיברנו כשדיברנו על Running Model?
כן, אולי אני אזכיר את זה. יותר חשוב לנו להגיד שהמודל בעצם עובד כך.
יש לנו פה Fix נכון? כמו תמיד בלי מומ.
עכשיו אחרי פיקס נגיד זה וואי אחד.
וואי שתיים או שלוש. וואי אנחנו רוצים לחזות את ההתפלגות על וואי חמש.
בהינתן וואי אחד עד ארבע. נכון?
אז מה אנחנו עושים? בארי אלן? אנחנו אומרים ככה אנחנו אומרים.
יש לנו איזושהי פונקציה רקורסיבית R, נכון?
אנחנו בסדר, יש לנו איזשהו Y אפס כאילו אין מצב או Hi 0 מצב התחלתי.
שאמרנו שאולי הוא פשוט אפסים או אחד הפרמטרים של המודל או משהו כזה נכון?
אז יש לנו איזשהו H1 אפס. אנחנו לוקחים את ה y אחד.
מקודדים אותו? כן אמרנו. יש איזשהו עם אנגלר? שהופכת אותו לווקטור?
כן, בוא נניח מראש שהוא כבר וקטור כדי להימנע מעוד סימון ויש את ה age 0 ואז RNA.
אני עובד עליהם ומייצר את H1.
ואז הוא מעביר את H1 לפה. ועוד פעם יש את R שהוא מייצר.
יחד עם ווי 2 את H2 וזה עובר את שלוש.
ואז אמרנו יש פונקצית Output. נכון שלוקחת את העץ הזה ומתרגמת אותו?
כן זה הפונקציה אור. אז אור של Hi 4.
כן זה בגדול איזשהו וקטור התפלגות.
על אוצר המילים נכון על פי שאנחנו מפרשים אותו.
ההסתברות של כל תוכן בהינתן תומכנים.
בסדר זה renal arena management זה מוכר?
מה ההבדל בין דר דיקר ודר ארכיטקט שחוץ מהסיפור הזה מה עוד יש?
בדיוק יש עוד אין קראודר. כלומר יש עוד, הרי אין. מה שמופיע פה אדום כן, שהוא מקבל גם הוא גם הרניה כמו הקודם.
ההבדל שלו זה שהוא בסוף לא פולט את זה.
הוא לא מזין וזה soft max שאז נותן את ההתפלגות של הרופאים הבאים תפקידו לייצר וקטור.
שבאיזשהו מובן מסכם את המשפט כי כאילו הוא פונקציה של כל הטורקים אם בסוף.
ועכשיו הדבר הזה מתנהל. כלומר, חוץ מ אפס זה מקבל גם את האין cover output.
כן. ואז. כולם מקבלים אותה.
או אולי רק ראשון. זה קצת תלוי בארכיטקטורה. אין כאן.
עשיתי את זה שרק הראשון מקבל אותו ואז אפשר לחשוב שהוא עידן סטייט.
פה בעצם כבר הכיל אותו, אז צריך להבהיר את כולם.
זה כבר דקויות. כן, אבל הרעיון הבסיסי הוא הדבר הזה מזין את תהליך החישוב.
ועכשיו בשאיפה ה HR בא ניקח בחשבון לא רק את אחד ה y 4, אלא גם את משפט המפתח.
לא. עכשיו זה רעיון סביר.
הבעיה שכמו שכתבתי אותו כאן הוא לא כל כך יפה.
כן, הוא לא כל כך יעבוד והסיבה לזה שהוא לא כל כך יעבוד.
הסיבה לזה אולי אתם יודעים קורסים קודמים.
מה הבעיה בגישה הזאת? על מה את?
כן. אוקיי, אז בעצם אז זה קשור לבן אישי?
גריידי אם? כן אה בעצם? ואז נהיה קצת יותר מפורשים אז לתפוס את המושכות.
כן, בדיוק. זאת אומרת, אפילו עם הגרדיאן, לא לגמרי. ומשם ראינו את זה.
נכון שככל שיש בכל זאת איזושהי גרידת, זה כפונקציה של המרחק.
בייחוד אם יש מסיחים באמצע דברים שיכולים כן לבלבל בעצם או כן להסיח את הדעת כאילו לגרום לו לקודד לא את הדברים הרלוונטי,
כמו שהרבה פעמים קורה בשפה של שהבקיעו עטים. או שבדיוק ידוע מה צריך להיות ההמשך?
ולכן מה הכי כדאי לזכור?
על כל פנים, אם תשימו לב, הקשר בין שפת המקור בשפת היעד, לפחות בארכיטקטורה הבסיסית הזאת כולה, עובר דרך צוואר הבקבוק,
שהוא הייצוג בעצם של המצב האחרון של ההדפסה, נכנס בהן בעצם התפקיד שלהן Code או לעשות איזשהו עם Code.
אולי זה הרנן, זה binary מעין, אולי יש לו כמה שכבות, לא משנה מה, הוא בסוף יוצר וקטור שאמור לייצג את כל המשפט.
זאת אומרת את כל המשפט דחסו לתוך וקטור אחד ועשינו את זה בצורה כזאת שבעצם המילים הראשונות במשפט כן.
כדי שהמילה הזאת תשפיע על הווקטור כאן, היא צריכה לעבור דרך כל הריקון, הפעלות, כן, הפעלות החוזרות של recording function.
כן, וראינו שיש את הגרידה עצמה ככל שהמרחק גדל. נכון?
אם אתם זוכרים את העבודה שהראיתי לגבי התאמה בין ספגטי ובר שקצת ראינו שיש השפעה של המרחק, אם לא אז נחזור לזה.
כן, דיברנו קצת על בת קצת תוצאות ניסוי איות לגבי זה שיש השפעה של המרחק.
אוקיי, יש איזושהי גרדת. ככל שמרחיקים בין ה output לבין האינפוט שלך זה מסתבך.
אז זה גם מה שקורה כאן. הכל חייב לעבור דרך צוואר הבקבוק הזה ולכן בעבודה מאוד משפיעה משנת 2004.
ומצטט אותה כאן לא? אולי כדאי שאני אוסיף כן, בעבודה מאוד משפיעה משנת 2014 של כן אחר שורשיה.
אני אוסיף את הרף שכל כך בעצם החליטו להוסיף עוד קומפוננטה, לסיפור ובמקום להעביר את הכל דרך End of silence.
עכשיו אמרו לא מה שאנחנו נעשה, כל מה שאנחנו נעשה זה אנחנו נדאג שיהיה.
אם ב דינג בעצם אנחנו נדאג שיהיה וקטור שייצג כל מילה בתור סנט.
אוקיי, הוא לא ייצג רק את המילה הזאת. הוא גם יהיה תוצאה של הרנין.
כן, כי אני לא רוצה לקחת ממש רק את המילה כפי שהיא כתובה שם.
אני רוצה שהוא כבר ייקח בחשבון את הקונטקסט. ואיזה עוד מילים מופיעות שם?
למה, אגב, אני מעדיף שהוא כבר ייקח את זה בחשבון? למה כשאני מייצג מילה?
בשורש אמ. אני לא פשוט רוצה לייצג אותה על ידי INPUT בידי עבודת טוקבק של שם.
כבר פחות משנה. כן, בדיוק. כי המשמעות עשויה להיות תלויה בהקשר נכון.
יש מובנים שונים. אנחנו רוצים עכשיו להתאים את זה למובן הספציפי.
אוקיי, אז אנחנו אומרים כן, נעביר את זה דרך Arms. נעביר את זה דרך עם קודי או אפילו כמה קודרים.
אולי הם הולכים גם הלוך חזור, לא משנה מה, בסוף אנחנו נקבל וקטור לכל מילה.
כבר לא וקטור אחד סמוי בפלייסטיישן לכל המשפט אלא וקטור לכל מילה שבאיזשהו מובן בארכיטקטורה אנחנו לא ניכנס פה לעומק כי זה גם כבר נהיה קצת Advanced,
אבל באיזשהו מובן אפשר בעצם לדאוג לזה שהדוקטור הזה ייצג בעיקר את המילה, אבל גם מייצג מידע על השכנים בצורה כזאת שבאמת עושה דשא בקרואטיה והרבה מקרים.
ועכשיו אנחנו נלמד עוד איזה מיני רשת כן שקראו לה attention.
אוקיי, מילה קשב שהרעיון שלה זה שמה שהרשת הזאת עושה זה היא מחליטה כמה משקל לתת לכל אחד מהמילים.
במשפט המקור היא מייצרת איזה שהם מקדמים של צירוף.
כמו כן מקדמים שהם מסכמים לאחד ואז היא מייצרת.
לא מייצרת קונטקסט וקטור. מי השילוב שלהם?
אתם יכולים להגיד טוב אם בסוף יצרת הקונטקסט וקטור.
אז גם פועל קונטקסט וקטורי קודר Output.
מה עשית בסיפור הזה ומה התשובה לזה?
על משקל המילה הראשונה, המילים. בדיוק.
אז בשאיפה אתה אומר בעצם מה שעשינו פה זה איזשהו סוג של write line math.
כן, ובגלל זה אני אומר שהאינטואיציה פה היא בהחלט מגיעה מאוד אליי.
מתי אומרת אם אני עכשיו רוצה לתרגם את המילה את הודיה, אז אני בעיקר צריך להסתכל פה, או בעיקר צריך לקחת בחשבון את זה.
ש. פה הסטודנט. כאילו כדי לתרגם את זה, סורי, אני בעיקר צריך להסתכל על מה שמופיע באנגלית אחרי Ein.
אה כן, אז וכדי לתרגם משהו אחר רצוי, אני בעיקר צריך להסתכל על אם.
או משהו כזה. כן, וכמובן שהמשפטים נהיים יותר ארוכים, יותר מורכבים.
בעיה זאת בייחוד עם תרגום. לא מילה למילה.
כן, מיד נדמה לך שנייה אחת. אז אני בעצם רוצה לעשות סוג של רו את אליין Meat, אבל בשונה מהמודלים הקודמים, זה מודלי מין.
דרך כן, בעצם אני אומר אני לוקח בחשבון חצי משלם, שליש נשאר נשאר ואני עושה אותו דינמי.
כן. אז בעצם יש איזושהי רשת קטנה שבכל מילה חדשה שאני חוזה ומשקרת לי מחדש את הווקטורים.
אם היא עושה עבודה טובה, היא עושה סוג של אם דבר כן שקרה היסטורית השיטה הזאת זה היה לפני שאני זוכר.
נכון בדיוק זה היה Attention. יוני זה היה יוני דתן של.
ואז זה אחריה. לא ככה קראו לה כן, אבל משהו כזה.
ושנתיים או שלוש שנים אחרי זה היה טל שאני זול.
יונית שאמר בעצם אתם הולכים לזרוק את הרננדז.
נדבר על זה. כן כן.
חוץ. איך באמת מצפים?
איך עובד דבר הזה? שוב אני מציג אותו בצורה אבסטרקטית כי אנחנו ניכנס לדברים הטכניים.
הטרנספורמר אני לא רוצה ללמד על גישה שכבר פחות משתמשים בה, אבל הרעיון חשוב לי.
שתבינו, הרעיון אומר את הדבר הבא. הוא אומר.
כאן היה באטלנטיק הכל חייב לעבור דרך האי S.
לכן, כדי שאיזה שהיא מילה תיכנס לבית דין של העיר OS,
היא צריכה הדרך היחידה שלה בסגנון הזה להיכנס זה בעצם לעבור דרך כל השלבים בדרך ולא להישכח, לא להידרס על ידי משהו אחר.
עכשיו לא לכל מילה יש את הווקטור שלה שהיא מזינה ישירות אותו.
גם לוקח בחשבון את השכנים, אבל אם מזינה ישירות אותו. והרשת הקטנה הזאת כן.
שמסומנת שם בריבוע ואז. מה שהיא עושה שם זה זה בעצם היא קובעת על סמך משפט המקור והפרי פיקס שכבר יצרתי
על סמך מה שאני כבר יודע הפרי פיקס במשפט המקור מה המשקלים של כל אחת מחתיכות.
ואז היא נותנת וקטור שהוא צרוף כמו לפי המשקלים שהיא חזתה.
של כל הווקטורים האלה. אז עכשיו כדי שמילה תילקח בחשבון?
אפילו אם היא בתחילת המשפט, כל מה שהיא צריכה לעשות זה לדאוג שהרשת הקטנה הזאת תדע לייחס לה משקל מספיק גדול.
אבל היא כבר לא צריכה לעבור דרך פה יכולה לעבור ישר כך.
אז אין מה לפחד והכל סבבה.
כבר נכנס ישירות לאור. כן, אז אור הוא פונקציה.
כן האור או לא משנה. כן כאן אפשר לחשוב עליו שהוא נכנס ישירות לאור.
או שהוא נכנס לA? זה לא כזה משנה. בוא נגיד אפילו שהוא נכנס.
אז עכשיו הקונטקסט וקטור? הוא דינמי.
זה לא אותו קונטקסט Vector לכל תחזית ותחזית.
כל פעם אני עושה צירוף כאמור אחר של הווקטורים שיצא להם Corner והם נכנסים כדי לחזות את המילה הבאה, אבל קצת עם הזיקה.
אוקיי, הקונטקסט נכון?
אז הדבר הזה עדיין לא עושה את Emotional. הדיכאון DIR.
אנחנו עוד מעט נראה גישה. הטרנספורמר שכן עושה את זה גם אם בצורה קצת מוגבלת.
תכף נדבר על. טוב אז זה הרנין פלוס attention זה בגדול מה שהסברתי מה שהסברתי עכשיו איך מאמנים רשתות כאלה?
בגדול האימון הוא ממש כמו שאנחנו זוכרים מהארנק language models.
כן, זה פשוט language model, רק שזה language שמודל שמזינה אותו עוד רשת בסדר.
אז צריך להעביר את הגרדיאן גם דרכה. אז מה שאנחנו עושים זה עדיין משתמשים בכוס אינטר פלוס בדיוק כמו קודם.
רק שעכשיו הP של טטה זה לא פי של תטא בין ווי לא פי של טטה של וי בהינתן הפרי פיקס, אלא p של טטה של y.
בהינתן הטראפיק ומשפט המקור, נכון, כי בעצם אנחנו מכניסים את הקונטקסט ווקטור או קוטר output וה training procedure.
זה עדיין בעצם מה שנקרא Therefore Sing שאנחנו כל פעם חוזים את המילה הבאה.
בהינתן FX של התרגום, כן, אתם זוכרים את הדבר הזה אם לא זוכרים?
לא לגמרי. אוקיי, אני אזכיר מה זה The Force. זה בעצם בדיוק אותה בעיה שדיברנו עליה גם בהקשר של.
של אין אלא. הרעיון הוא כזה.
איך אני מייצר דוגמאות אימון כדי לאמן את הרשת שלי?
אני לוקח זוגות משפטים וכל פעם לוקח משפט המקור וננסה לחזות את המילה הראשונה.
אוקיי, זה דוגמת אימון אחת דוגמת אימון הבא.
זה משפט המקור פרי פיקס באורך אחד של המילה הראשונה בתרגום לנסות לחזות את המילה השנייה.
דוגמה שלישית משפט המקור שתי מילים ראשונות זאת המילה.
וכן, מה הבעיה עם זה או מה פוטנציאלית הבעיה?
כן, נראה לי ששמתי פה אפילו כן. שמתי פה אפילו שקף שבעצם יש דיסקרטית C.
יש אי התאמה פוטנציאלית בין הטרנינג לבין הטקסט.
מאיפה נובעת התופעה הזאת? בטקסט בעצם אנחנו מתנים אולי.
אולי קודם אני אגיד משהו לגבי בעצם ה influence ואז אני אדבר.
אבל בגדול, כפי שאנחנו נראה בטקסט אנחנו.
עושים. בעצם אנחנו מכניסים פרי ופקסים שהם נוצרו על ידי מכונה ובאימון אנחנו מכניסים פה פקסים שהם פרי פקסים של תרגום שכנראה בן אדם יצר כן,
לא שהוא לא הוא חלק מהם Training data.
למה בעצם אני אומר שזה המצב? אוקי, בוא נסתכל קצת איך פועל האימפקט.
כן. אז איך פועל האינפרה בגדול זה גם כאן.
זה כמו במודל שפה. קצת דיברנו על זה, נגיד.
גישה אחת זה לעשות גרידי, דיכאון. כן, כל פעם להתחיל מסתערת, להסתכל.
נגיד שאלף בית שלי זה ידעי או אין שאומר שאני רוצה לסיים את התרגום.
אין לאפסן כאן כזה את הטקסט, אז אני יכול כל פעם פשוט לקחת גרידי.
לי כן, יש לי אפס חמש לA ורק אפס ארבע לסין ועוד פחות מזה לאחרים.
אז אני אבחר את A אחרי A. אני מסתכל על המילה הבאה.
בהינתן AA שוב בוחר AE כי זה יותר גבוה מהאחרים וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
וככה באופן חמדנית אני גם יכול לעשות b search and שאני אזכיר לכם מה זה פעם search.
נתקלתם בזה בעבר? לא? אוקיי, אז אני לא אזכיר לכם, אבל אני אסביר לכם מה זה פעם Search כי כתבתי גם פוסט דקות.
Bin search זה רעיון דומה לך חמדני. זה רעיון דומה לך חמדני, אבל קצת פחות.
איך הוא? איך הוא בעצם עובד? אני כל פעם מחזיק לא אחד, לא קנדי.
דת אחד בעצם שאני כל פעם מעריך אותו בדרך האופטימלית,
כי אני אומר יכול להיות שאם עכשיו אני אבחר פה את המילה AA, אז מה או לא משנה, אני אבחר פה את A ואז b.
אולי אני אגלה שבעצם אם הייתי בוחר את חיי A ואז E זה המקסימום.
כן יותר גדול מ ואז b. אז אני אגלה שאחרי A היא בעצם אין לי אופציות כל כך טובות.
כן? ולעומת זאת אחרי AB כן יש לי אופציות טובות, אבל מה לעשות כבר בחרתי e אז אני תקוע.
אז מה אני אעשה? במקום זאת אני בעצם מחזיק. אני אפתח כמה קלפים הם קוראים, איזה מין קרן אני אפתח מין אלומה?
אוקיי של מסלולים. אבל טוב.
אלומה זה נחמד רק שיש מספר אקספוננציאלי שהמסלול נכון.
כגודל אוצר המילים כזה כגודל אוצר המילים בריבוע. אחרי זה כגודל אוצר המילים בשלישית אלומה זה נחמד אבל כן יהרוג אותנו אז לא.
אז נפרדים search זה אומר בעצם את הדבר הבא תחזיק Priority.
קיו תחזיק Priority קיוב. תפתח בי מצבים.
כן, בהתחלה תתחיל מרק Start. תפתח בי.
כן. במילים אחרות תפתח משתאות לכל המצבים האפשריים באוצר מילים.
אוקיי, כל המצבים האפשריים באוצר המילים. וכל אחד מהם תיתן לו value שהוא פשוט כן value שלו, שזה אפילו הקודם כפול ההסתברות של המעבר.
כן של להוסיף את התו הזה בסוף ולדחוף את זה חזרה לפיו.
לובטקין. בסדר, אבל אז בסוף השלב אז עכשיו בגודל Priority קיו שלי אחרי צעד אחד.
V. נכון, פתחתי את כולם, אבל אז בסוף כל אחד אני זורק.
את כולם חוץ מהמקסימום BL. אוקיי, אז אני זורק את כל הביו מינוס B אחרים.
עכשיו נשאר לי רק B. אוקיי, אז יש לי אלומה בגודל B.
מחזיר את כולם לפרי הוא. מתחיל חזרה.
עכשיו יש לי כח, יש לי מצבים, כל אחד מהם אני יכול לפתח לכמה אפשרויות.
ועוד פעם. אז עכשיו יש לי די הרבה.
כן וי ועוד B פחות אחד.
דברים שאני מסתכל עליהם. שוב אני זורק את הכל חוץ מבי הראשונים.
נמשיך הלאה וכן הלאה וכן הלאה. ויש לי Priority שאומר לי כל פעם את מה לפתח עד שאני עד שכולם מגיעים לסוף.
או או או נשפטים באמצע מנופים באמצע. ואז אני בוחר בין אלה.
כן. בין האלומות שהגיעו לסוף, בין המסלולים של פירסט.
אז זה חצי גרידי, נכון? כי כאילו מצד אחד אני אני, יש לי פה משהו שהוא חמדני, נכון?
בזה שאני זורק את כולם חוץ מהגביע ראשונים. יכול להיות שזרקתי מישהו שהוא במקום פלוס אחד, ודווקא אם הייתי מפתח אותו הייתי מגלה אותו.
אין מה לעשות, פספסתי. אבל מצד שני זה לא לגמרי גרידי כי בכל זאת אני מחזיקה.
בסדר. אגב, גריידי הוא מקרה פרטי של פיצוץ.
כן, כפי שאמר לך מה בי שווה אחד אומר.
תפתח! תזרוק את כולם חוץ מהמקסימום, תפתח אותו כשר אחד על כולם חוץ ממך.
זה בדיוק גרידי מה שקראנו. בסדר, זה פשוט איזושהי הכללה של.
גרידי קצת פחות גרידי. שאלות על זה.
ויש עוד כל מיני שיטות אינטרנט, אבל בגדול מה שמשותף לכולם זה באמת בדיוק הבעיה הזאת.
כן, האקספלורר ריצ'רד בייס, מה שלפעמים קוראים או הדיסקט פנסי הזה שיוצר עתיד של פרסים ומימון לבית העסק במימון.
אני מתנה על פריסת איקסים של תרגום נכון באינטרנט או של תרגום שבן אדם יצר האם French.
אני מתנה פשוט על Output של המודל עד אותה נקודה לפחות output אפשרי של המודל בפינטרסט, אבל זה לא יהיה בדיוק output אבל יהיה איזושהי קנדידה cloud.
ויש כל מיני דרכים לנסות להתגבר על זה.
זה באמת יוצר בעיה. זאת אומרת, זה לא בעיה תיאורטית. זאת בעיה אמיתית, כן שנתקלים בה ויש כל מיני דרכים לנסות לתקן אותה.
העיקרית ביניהם שבשימוש היום היא שימוש בטכניקות של influence learning.
שניגע בהם ממש קצת. בסוף הקורס אני חושב שמדברים עליהם קצת יותר בקורס מתקדם ב NLP.
אבל יש גם שיטות אחרות להחליף את ה לא ספאנשן, למרות שזה די מסבך את האימון ובגלל זה פחות עושים את זה.
לאמן אותו בעצם על Data סינתטי. כן, זה גם משהו שלפעמים עושים.
זאת אומרת, לוקחים את המודל, מאמנים אותו עד איזשהי נקודה שכבר נראה שהוא מתחיל להוציא.
דברים מתקבלים על הדעת, גם אם לא מושלמים. ועכשיו מייצרים data סינתטי, כלומר מייצרים חוטים של המודל ומאמנים אותו עליהם.
Therefore, Sing. כמובן שבהם. זה זה שאם משתמשים גם להאזין לו זה כן כן, זה בדיוק הבאלאנס שאתם איכשהו צריכים להיזהר.
מנסים לא יותר מדי זבל לבין להתאים את האימון ואת האינפורמציה לשם.
אוקיי. בסדר וכל הדבר הזה אפשר לחשוב עליו.
מוטיבציה. למה בעצם הטרנספורמר?
אבל זה גם באמת היסטורית. ההקשר שבו הטרנספורמר התפתח.
כן, עם הזכרת נכון את המאמר של איתן, שמצד ימין זה בעצם מאמר שעוסק בתרגום.
נכון, אחרי זה משם זה כבר התפתח לכל מיני כיוונים, אבל במקור זה ההקשר שבו הארכיטקטורה הזאת,
שהיום משתמשים בה גם ב speech ובייג'ין וגנטיקה נראה לי גם יש פה.
נכון, יש פה נציגים של זה. כן, הבנתי שמשתמשים בזה, לא זה פלייס.
היא התחילה בתגובה בעצם. טוב.
אז הרעיון של הטרנספורמר זה שבעצם כן אתם?
אוקיי, בעצם דיברנו עד עכשיו על Attention כאיזשהו עדכון כזה.
נכון כאיזשהו תוסף על כדי לתקן איזושהי בעיה בעינינו.
נכון, זה שצריך להעביר תוכן הם רחוקים איכשהו צריכים להעביר את הסיגנל שלהם דרך, הרבה הרבה טוקבקים באמצע, ואנחנו צריכים לייצר להם דרך קיצור.
הרעיון של המאמר הזה זה שבעצם ארמניים הם קצת כאב ראש, כי אמרנו שיש להם competition groups מאוד עמוקים.
נכון, והם גם תלויים באורך המשפט וזה מקשה למקבל אותם נדבר על זה קצת.
בסוף יש להם בעיות טכניות מסוימות עם הארמנים והאתר והיינו מצליחים לבנות Feed Forward Network,
אבל fed Forward network צריך להיזהר באיך בונים אותה נכון, כי אם פשוט נבנה אותה בצורה נאיבית.
מה שנקרא fully connected אז אנחנו בבעיה.
נכון, כי אז שוב אנחנו כמה פרמטרים.
אנחנו צריכים המון, כי בעצם ה input צריך להיות בגודל ברור של המשפט.
נכון זה וכל אחת מהמילים מיוצגת אולי על ידי כמה מאות פיצ'רים.
אז רק שכבת ה input כוללת המון המון דברים ואז אני צריך כל אחד.
קיצור זה נשמע מאוד קשה.
גם הרשת היא גם גדולה ואולי עוד יותר גרוע מזה הספר.
City הוא נורא גדול וזאת בעיה. אז אולי אפשר להשתמש בטנג'יר?
כן. ואיך? ומה בעצם הרעיון?
הרעיון הוא לעשות איתן שנים. שמזינים אחד את השני.
כן, כל מיני במקום שעיר ימני יזין את tension cream ינתן שמאלה tension tension.
אז איך זה עובד? אז מי שלא ידע קודם צריך להבין מושג שנקרא circle.
עד עכשיו דיברנו בעצם על attention נכון? באיזה הקשר אמרנו?
אנחנו חושבים לזה כמו קשב. יש כל מיני דברים שאני צריך לשים אליהם לב.
נכון? בעצם אני צריך לעשות איזשהו soft line שאמרנו בין הסוס לבין אתר get להחליט איזה חלקים חשובים אני רוצה לקדם לעשות.
ובעצם אני. אני חושב על זה כמין סוג של קשב מוגבל.
כן, איזשהו איזשהו קשב מוגבל. יש לי Confessions, כן מקדמים שמסתכמים לאחד.
אני אחלק אותם בדרך של זמן, אומרת לי מה החלקים הכי חשובים להסתכל עליהם?
למה המילה הזאתי היא אלמנט, אבל בצורה soft ובצורה דינמית?
סטן צ'ן אומר בעצם אני יכול להסתכל.
הווקטורים של המילים יכולים להסתכל על עצמם ולכל מילה, לייצר וקטור חדש שמסתמך על כל המילים.
אוקיי, אז במקום עכשיו לעשות את tension שמסתכל על המילים בשורש ומייצר מילה הבאה output.
אני גם יכול לעשות self attention. כן, שהמילים בסוף יסתכלו אחת על השניה וייצרו ייצוג חדש של המילים בסוף שמבוסס על הייצוגים של המילים הקודמות.
אוקיי, אז מה הרעיון כאן?
אז נגיד שבאמת אני רוצה לקודד איזשהו משפט ואני רוצה שכל מילה יהיה לה קידוד שהוא תלוי גם בשכנים שלה, לאו דווקא השכנים והמילים האחרות שנמצאות בטקסט.
כן, אפילו לשכנים מיידיים בכך. אז למשל, אני רוצה לקחת את המשפט אם אתם מצליחים לקרוא את זה, למרות שזה זה,
אני אקריא It's in the Spirit data, מג'ר היוטיוב, אמריקן Government, הרוטס ניו לא שינסו את האוזניים.
Making registration אורוות ing process more difficult.
ונגיד שאתם עכשיו תרצו לתרגם את זה נגיד לעברית.
אוקיי, אז המילה טו מייק משהו more difficult.
בעברית. אז אפשר להפוך נכון או לפעמים להקשות?
להקשות. בהרבה מקרים זה יהיה נכון להקשות על. הליך הרישום וההצבעה או משהו כזה, נכון?
אז בעצם כדאי להסתכל. ולעומת זאת mako כמו mako יהיה רגע אחר.
בדיוק להכין או לאפות או לא יודע נכון? אז משהו אחר אז כדאי כדי.
אז מה שהייתי רוצה זה שהייצוג של מייק.
ייקח בחשבון גם את מול Difficult.
אוקיי, גם פיצ'רים של מודיפיקציות. כדי לעשות לו סוג של דיס דקורציה.
שוב, זה הכל נפנופי ידיים זה הכל קורה על ידי הרשת הופכות.
הרעיון הוא שאם אני אתן לרשת את ההזדמנות לעשות את זה ואז האמן אותה, היא כבר תצליח למצוא את החיבורים.
כן? לא שאני מראש בונה את רשת, זה לא הארט ווייט, כן, אבל זה לבנות את הארכיטקטורה ככה שהיא תוכל לייצג כאלה הכללות.
אוקיי, אז בעצם מה שאני עושה זה אני מנסה ללמוד מקדמים.
על המילים במשפט. ככה שכשאני אייצר את הגרסה הבאה.
של ייצוגים של אינספור המשפט, הם כבר ייקחו בחשבון את המילים הרלוונטיות האחרות במשפט.
אז. אז אם מי כמו Difficult וביחד יכול אולי להיתרגם למילה אחת.
בשפת היעד כמו להקשות, אז אולי הייתי רוצה ללמוד באמת.
שכדי לייצר את האין Padding של Making אני רוצה להסתכל גם על making וגם על More Difficult ואולי גם על עוד קצת דברים,
אבל נגיד לא כל כך על History שנובע שוטינג process כי הם לא נורא משפיעים על איך אני אתרגם את Making.
אוקיי, אז זה פחות או יותר הרעיון. אז הייתי רוצה ללמוד משהו שאולי יכול ללמוד את המפה כן תיתן שם, אז את אתה מקדמים.
בסדר המוטיבציה. הוא. כן, כי באמת יש המון סוגים של מייק.
כן, מייק Difficult זה פשוט ומייק כן. כל הדברים האלה.
אמרתי. מייק סמול לאף זה לא הצחיק בכלל.
מייק dogs breakfast over אתם מכירים את הביטוי ביטוי בריטי?
לא. אוקיי, זה לעשות משהו כאילו לפשל כאילו, אבל זה ממש ביטוי כזה.
לגמרי כן. די מייד! The dogs breakfast of the present nation.
תודה customers. כן, זה אומר שהם עשו שם בלאגן נורא.
ובקיצור, כפי שאתם מבינים אין לזה שום קשר לארוחת בוקר.
אני אגיד בעברית. כן, הם הכינו ארוחת בוקר לכלבים, מהמצגת, ללקוחות.
נראה שזה לא התקבל בהבנה. אז צריך להבין, אוקיי, צריך להבין שזה הדברים האלה מתחברים ביחד ושמי מקבל את ההקשר שלו לפיזיקה.
אז זה הרעיון של סל פטנט שכל פעם לבנות ייצוג יותר ויותר עדין.
כמובן שאפשר לחזור על זה כמה פעמים. כן, כי אולי גם difficult הוא עצמו גם בגיוס סגרו כדי לייצר ייצוג.
טוב, לא? אני גם צריך להסתכל על מילים אחרות ואולי גם האם אני צריך כאילו נכון, יש תלויות התלויות רק צריך וחלקם ציק להיות גם נכון.
שתי מילים שהם כל אחת כן. נגיד למשל למייק Dogs Breakfast.
נכון, Dogs Breakfast, כאילו דג בפני עצמו הוא כלא ופרויקט ארוחת בוקר ומייק זה להכין להפוך וואטאבר.
אבל Dogs Breakfast ביחד זה אומר בלאגן. אז אם קודם אני מחבר אותם כבר בשכבה הבאה זה הופך לבלאגן ואז זה יכול להתחבר למייק.
אולי זה לא משנה. אז כאילו הרעיון הוא שכשעושים את זה בהרבה שכבות, אולי אני יכול בעצם לקבל אקספרסיביות יותר גדולה, אז אפשר לחזור על זה כמובן.
בייחוד אם זה טקסט ארוך ומורכב, עם הרבה קשרים סמנטיים וקשרים עדינים וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
בסרט. אז. אוקיי, אני רואה שנגמר הזמן, אז בואו נצא להפסקה ונחזור עוד רבע שעה ואז נתחיל לדבר על ממש על משינה.
אבל. אני רוצה לחשוב מה שאני רוצה.
חושבת שאת רוצה לדבר. יש לשלב, אבל אני רוצה להיות שם קודם.
דיברנו על זה, קרה לי משהו לספר לך. משהו על החיים בכלל לא נכון.
אז אתה בעצם אומר אני מסתכל עליך כאילו אתה עושה סט של דברים שאני מסתכל סביב זה.
אתה רוצה לייצר תחליף לזה?
לא רק לא בשבילי. אבל נשאלת השאלה משחקת תפקיד.
זה חשוב שהקצב יחסית. נכון, אבל לא צריך שיהיה צפוף מדי.
רוצה להכניס לראש, לא להתרפס בשביל לכסות מה זה?
זה שלא פוסח על המילים בסוף כדי לייצר עוד שם.
כן, זה אומר שאת עכשיו כמו שצריך, אבל בזמן שעשית את.
אתה רוצה לייצר סוג של רייטינג שהוא מבוסס גם על הייצוג בשכבה הקודמת של המיינסטרים, אבל גם של מוזיקת פופ.
אבל אתה עדיין רוצה לייצג את אותן מילים. דבר שני, תוספת של הייצוג שעשינו בתחילת התחילה.
ואז הראשון שעשינו ניסינו לעשות את המילה הבאה בתור.
אני לא רוצה לחזור על מה שקורה כאן.
שוב אתה אומר אני רוצה. זה כאילו אתה אומר אני רוצה לייצג את הכחולים בצורה יותר טובה.
אז אני לא אפיל עליהם. הרידינג כמו שעשו כאן. אני אלמד, מקדמים עליהם וייצר גרסה חדשה טובה יותר של הכחול.
ועכשיו הקונטקסט הוא מוזר.
נפלתי קורבן, כתב. הוא יוצא מהתחרות.
צריך את ההתפוצצות, אני אתן שם. נכון.
אז הכל בסדר פשוט. אין לי מושג איפה לקחת את המשפט לצרכי הסביצ'ה.
אוקיי. ואז זה נראה שאני משתמש נכון.
פה אני אומרת לך את הדבר הזה ונכניס בכל פעם להקריא ואז ננסה ללמוד כשהיית יותר שלם.
כן, מאמץ קל וכל מילה תיוצג טוב יותר.
במחקר הראשון עשיתי את קישרתי בינינו שאחרי זה מייקל קנדי פלוס בהקשר של עודד בן עמי, גדי וכל פלג משהו אחר, ואז עם השני קצת טריקי.
נכון, אתם לא כל כך מתנגדים כמו בכל שכבה כולם מתעסקים.
אז שכבה ראשונה כמו שתי משפחות, נגיד כן. אז ככה שתי המשפחות להתעלם.
יש איזה מייק אפ לכסות אותו.
אולי נכון להגיד אותו פעמיים ואז. טוב, אז כן, אנחנו ממש צריכים הדדיות כפי.
שאת אמרת יש.
לך. כבר עשרים אופציות לא?
היית מדבר בסוף על חסרונות שעשיתי באפריקה, אבל הוספתי את השטות הזאת.
מסתבר שאת צריכה ללמוד תורה וחסד שבהם את מספרת על עצמך.
במהלך. אך אף.
אנחנו. כל.
עברתי. השתלת עדשות?
לא בפני עצמו, אבל זוהי האפשרות.
אותן. מתוך רצון.
ההחלטה התקבלה בעקבות התערבות פולשנית שהסתבכה.
אז אתן צריכות לעשות?
משהו? אז תבדוק את השירים שלך בצד.
בסוף זה עשה לי. תמונה משביעת רצון.
בסופו של דבר אני לא זוכרת את הפעם.
הראשונה מלחמת העולם השנייה שהרגשת צליפת שוט.
זה? ככה להחזיר שאלה תיאורטית, כאילו לא ללכת עד הסוף בשביל להנות מזה שהוא לא משתתפת בסדנאות.
אז אי אפשר היה לפספס את אליסה בארץ.
אז הצלחתי פשוט להמשיך בתוכנית גם בשנה שעברה בשנה שעברה.
אבל בסופו של דבר, אז כן, זה מה שנקרא את הסרט לעשות.
אבל את מה שחשבנו ששרדנו בזכות. תוסיף לזה שאלה יש ללמוד.
אפילו סמסטר אחד עכשיו, אבל זה ממש להתחיל כבר מעכשיו.
אני רוצה לתת לשניים חשבון בהנחה שכדאי אני בפרויקט, כלומר למשך כמה שבועות בכלל לך.
אנחנו ממשיכים. כשאנחנו בסופו.
אז. לנו משהו.
בעוד שאת נוטלת מזה מספר שנים, אני לא חושבת שגם גם כאן.
אנחנו. חיים ועובדים, אבל התוצאה גן כן.
אני צריכה לעשות קצת סדר. מה עושים במקרה כבר?
אבל עכשיו לעשות אותו דבר אתה צריך להיכנס לצד השני.
שאנחנו לא צריכים אדם אמריקאי ששמו האמיתי של האמריקאים.
כמעט כולם צודקים.
אני רוצה להזכיר. לך שאת הסמארטפון זה כבר מזמן לא כזה סיפור פה בנושא של דברים שצריך פשוט.
לשחק. כשנותנים לזה פרס, סתם ככה.
על. סמך.
אוקיי. אז בואו ניכנס עוד קצת פנימה.
אז. לגבי איך עובד self tension.
בנקודות של הטרנספורמר. אז בגדול שכבה של צרפת אין שם כרגע.
זה מציג את זה בצורה סכמטית. תכף נראה שיש לה גם עוד קצת חלקים, אבל בצורה סכמטית היא בעצם נכנסים אליה וקטורים שהם מייצגים.
את המילים בו. כן, בסוף נסכם במשפט המקור יכול להיות שהם כבר output של שכבה קודמת של סרטן שכבר איכשהו ערבבה או לקחה מידע מ וקטור אחד לאחר.
הדברים האלה נכנסים לשכבת הגיל קטן של שכבת גיל.
הפטנט שם זהות למנגנון. הפטנט של מנגנון מתן שם הזן מייצר וקטורים שיסמן אותם בזנים.
כן, הווקטורים בעצם הגרסה הבאה ביציאה מהשם קפטן צ'ן.
אחרי זה הווקטורים האלה נכנסים לאיזשהו פיד Forward Network, שמאפשר בעצם לרשת קצת יותר אקספרסיביות, כי בעצם מה שזה מאפשר לה.
זה. זה ללמוד איזשהם טרנספורמציות שמעבר לצירוף קמור של הווקטורים שהזינו אליה.
אז נותן עוד קצת אקספרסיביות ומשם זה בעצם יוצא החוצה לשכבה הבאה.
אוקיי, אז איך זה עובד? נתחיל בדוגמה ואחרי זה נראה את זה.
במקרה היותר כללי לוקח בעצם הדוגמה כבר די מראה את המקרה הכללי הזה.
טוב, אז האינפוט שלנו הם אם אין סכנה שנכנסים.
נגיד שיש שם איקס אחד ו x 2. נגיד למשל שאחד מייצג את thinking והשני מייצג את בשיט.
אוקיי. אנחנו בעצם מייצרים לכל אחד מהמילים.
לכל אחד מהם פרטים Padding אחד ואיקס 2 מייצרים שלושה וקטורים.
אוקיי, הווקטורים האלה נוצרים. לא משנה מה אינדקס שהמילה הווקטורים האלה פשוט נוצרים על ידי האינדקס שהמילה כפול מטריצה נלמדת שזה חלק מהפרמטרים של המותר.
אז בעצם יש לנו שלוש מטריצות דאבל דאבל קיי ואתה בליווי.
כן, המטריצות האלה מכפילות פעם אחת את איקס אחד, פעם אחת, רק שתיים.
אם היה לנו יותר מכפיל גם את שלוש ארבע. את כל האינדקסים השנים מכפילים ומייצרים וקטורים.
בעצם שלוש סדרות חדשות של וקטורים. במקרה כאן שלוש זוגות קווי אל אחד אנחנו נקרא קווי ריס.
כן, מכפלות של אותה דאבל דאבל קיו בפקטור אנחנו נקרא Current קיז זה והמכריע של דבר אוקיי, ובעל US המכפלה בתא בליווי.
אוקיי, אז זה השלב הראשון. אנחנו יוצרים בעצם זוגות כאלה של זוג.
עכשיו מה שאנחנו עושים זה בעצם מכפילים את כל הזוגות של קיוב וקיי.
אוקיי, אז בעצם כדי לחשב את זה D1 כן Padding של thinking אנחנו נכפיל את אחד בכ 1 ואת אחד K2 כדי לייצר את Machines.
אנחנו נכפיל את CO2 בקו אחד ואת שתיים שתיים בסדר, אז אנחנו בעצם יוצרים את הפר is not products של k של הקיז וה cruise ומקבלים איזה שהם score.
אוקיי, אז score זה אלה הם בעצם מה שישמש אותנו כדי כדי בעצם לקבוע מה המקדם של אותה מילה בצירוף הכמות.
אז למשל thinking. אוקיי, אני אומר, כדי לייצר עכשיו את זה יד אחד, כלומר את הייצוג output שטחי King.
מה שאני צריך זה בעצם לקחת את קיו אחד את הקווירי שלו ולהכפיל אותו בכל הקיי.
במקרה כאן רק אחד. וכי 2. אני מכפיל אותם ורואה שהם מכפלה של קיר אחד בכל אחד מ 112 ושל קיר אחד כי 296.
זה בעצם יהיה הבסיס שלי, שלפיו אני אקבע בעצם המקרה הזה של שסליחה שאחד כאילו שבעצם ההשפעה של האינדקס הראשון היא יותר גדולה במשהו מההשפעה של X2.
מה טכנית קורה? אז מה שקורה זה שאני לוקח את העסקות האלה מחלק אותן בקבוע.
ספציפית, השורש של כן הוא גודל המטריצה.
לא משנה. אולי אני אגיד על זה מילה. בסוף, בחלק באיזושהי קבוע שהוא פשוט קבוע של הרשת, הוא לא נלמד.
הוא נקבע לפי הארכיטקטורה של הרשת במקרה כמו שמונת אוקיי.
מחלק באיזשהו קבוע, מקבל 14 ו 12 מפעיל על גבי זה Soft Max.
כלומר עד כדי חלוקה בקבוע. הסכומים האלה של המכפלות השכליות הם בעצם המקדמים.
הם לא ג'ינס של המקדמים.
כאילו אחרי סוף מקס הם יהפכו המקדמים ואני רואה שזה יוצא 080 12 כן, אז אני צריך לקחת 88 אחוז מן אינדקס אחד ו 12 אחוז אינדקס 2 ולייצר את זה ב 1.
יפה עכשיו. האם אני לוקח את 1088 כפול X אחד ועוד 012 כפול x 2 כמעט מה שאני עושה זה בעצם אתם
זוכרים שיש לי גם מידע בלובי שיצא לי את V1 V2 אני לוקח בעצם צירוף קמור שלהם,
אז זה בעצם לא היה לגמרי מדוייק מה שאמרתי קודם שאני לומד צירופים קמורים על האינפוט Factors עם Confessions דינמיים.
דבר יותר מדוייק להגיד זה שאני לומד מטריצה קבועה.
כן איזושהי מטריצה קבועה דאבליו V ואז אני מייצר את הזה קצר.
אופים כמורים. של הטרנספורמציה של האינפוט בסדר הזה.
זה כמעט קבוצות צירוף כמו. של הטרנספורמציה שלהם לפי דבליו שהיא מטריצה.
אוקיי, ואז אני מקבלת זד אחד. איך אני עושה את זה?
שתיים באופן אנלוגי לחלוטין. כן, במקרה כאן יהיה לי את CO2.
אני צריך להכפיל אותו פעם אחת בכל אחד. פעם אחת בפי שתיים אני אקבל מספרים, אני אחלק אותם, אני אעשה להם בסוף מקס אני אקבל מקדמים.
אני אקח את הווים שוב ואעשה להם קומבינציה לפי המקדמים החדשים.
אוקי, אז רק שניה אחת. אז אם תשימו לב. בעצם בעצם.
דרך הדרך היחידה שבה.
זה אחד וזה שתיים הם שונים. מה הדבר היחידי שהופך את זה לחד בעצם 2 לשומעים?
זה זה זה בעצם כן, זה בעצם מקורי והקהל עיוור.
פשוט מכפלה של איזושהי מטריצה כפול איקס אחד באקסטרים.
אז עכשיו אני אשאל אתכם את השאלה הזאת. בוא נגיד שהייתי לוקח את אותם איקס אחד באקסטרים.
ופשוט מחליף ביניהם את הסדר. משאיר אותם ההפך.
היה קורה משהו. כן, פשוט האאוטפיט המתחלף.
אבל כאילו זה בעצם היה בדיוק אותו דבר. זה סימטרי לגמרי. בסדר, כרגע עוד לא הסברתי, זה מוזר.
פעם ראשונה שקראתי את המאמר הזה. הייתי מאוד מופתע. הייתי אומר אוקיי, אבל thinking machine זה לא כמו machine thinking, נכון?
אז איפה המידע הזה נכנס? הוא לא באיקס אחד ואיקס שתיים.
אולי כן. אז מסתבר שכן, אבל בדרך שעוד לא הסברתי איך היא פועלת.
כן, כרגע זה קצת מוזר כי אין משמעות בכלל הסדר.
מה קרוב למי מקרוב? למה? השאלה היתה. איך נוצר ובחלוף?
ספור כן, זה אחד או פשוט אפס.
88 V1 ועוד 1012 V2. בסדר, תכף נראה את הנוסחה הכללית.
אז הנוסחה הכללית אומרת כך. זה יעבור מה שעוד מעט נקרא single head, אבל כרגע בוא נקרא לזה פשוט התנגשות.
כן. איך עובדת tension?
יש לך עם פוטים איקס אחד עתיק 2 סדרה של ווקטורים.
באיזשהו מימד נתון יש מטריצות שמתרגמת את המימד מטילות או טרנספורמציה של האינפוט עם האלה לאיזשהו מימד פנימי.
של לאיזשהו מימד פנימי של הבטן, של Head הזה, של מנגנון ה attention סדר שזה איזשהו היפר פרמטר.
זה הדי ג'יי הזה. או. קיי בסדר הזה ממפות אותם.
בעצם קיום K וביט שאיך הם מתקבלות?
כן. אז פשוט נוח לחשוב על זה. מטרי ציוני.
אז את האיקסים? אתה יכול פשוט לחשוב עליהם כמת. ריצה כן כמת ריצה שבעצם אתה מסדר אותם כך שכל אחת מהעבודות תתאים ל Instant.
כן. אז יש לך שתי שורות ומימד הקאמפ input dimension ואין עמודות בסדר.
עכשיו לקחת והכפלת אותם בדאבל קיו דבליו דבליו זה בעצם אותו דבר.
להכפיל כל אחד מהם בדבליו דבליו דבליו V כמו להכפיל פשוט את כל המטריצה.
נכון? אז תקבל מטריצה חדשה מטריצות חדשות, שלוש מטריצות שבהן כל עמודה מתאימה לאינדקס אחד באינדקס אחד.
זה יפה. מה אתה עכשיו עושה? אתה לוקח את המכפלות השכליות של כל הזוגות, של כינויים וכן.
נכון מה שבעצם ראינו קודם כל המכפלות של King.
במקרה אחד אין כל כך הרבה. כן, יש לנו פשוט קיר אחד כי אחד כי הוא אחד.
K2 ועבור X2 זה יהיה CO2 כאחד co2 K2.
אבל אם יש לך אין כאלה אז יש לך. אין בריבוע הזאת בסדר אז פשוט המכפלה הזאת.
כן נכון מכפלה זה פשוט זה כפול Transport זה בדיוק יתן לך את כל הקומבינציות ואז בעצם קיבלת מטריצה בגודל כמה?
אין מה לחשוב על זה. אינטואיטיבית היו לנו אין וקטורים.
נכון. אחרי זה הם תורגמו לאין וקטורי כי ואין וקטורי Carry.
ועכשיו עשית את כל המכפלות בזוגות. כמה מכפלות בדיוק יש לך בריבוע שמוצגים המטריצה.
נכון, האינטראקציה בין כל זוג. בין כל זוג וקטור בסדר חילק את באיזשהו קבוע.
כאמור, זה איזשהו סוג. אין להם שם באמת הצדקה.
תאורטית קצת מנפנפים ידיים בפרלמנט. דווקא בחוק הזה אני מאמין שהם ניסו כל מיני דברים, לא משנה.
יש שם איזה שהוא קבוע, הוא לא נלמד שורש של דיקי ועכשיו מה שאתה.
מה שאתה עושה זה בעצם אתה עושה soft max. כן, עכשיו זה מוטציה, זו מוטציה מאוד מקובלת, אבל היא טיפה מבלבלת.
כן, מה זה soft מקס על המטריצה הזאת? בדיוק נכון?
אז כאילו אנחנו בעצם צריכים לעשות לכל כל שורה על כל דף זה גם בעצמי מתבלבל מזה שניה אחת אנחנו צריכים בעצם עכשיו אם הוא הולך להיות וקטור של עמודות.
נכון, כל דוגמה זה עמודה וספרות אז אז אז אנחנו צריכים שטח.
אז בעצם הוא הולך לכפול סקלרית את זה, את זה, את זה, את זה, את זה, את זה, את זה.
אז מה שהיה אז בעצם הוא הביא.
הזה הולך להיות קומבינציה. כן.
כן. אז בעצם כל שורה צריכה להסתכם באחד?
כן. כנראה.
כן. שהוא קצת. רגע שנייה אני אצייר את זה אז אני אראה תוך שנייה.
אבי אבי, איך הוא נראה?
אבי? אבי הוא מטריצה בגודל D.
אם אין זה מתאים לאינדקס. כן, אז זה וי אחד ושתיים וי.
כן? אוקיי, עכשיו אני רוצה להכפיל את זה מצד שמאל.
נכון, זה V. אני רוצה להכפיל את זה מצד שמאל ב.
כן, במטריצה הזאת M של המכפלה של Keys וקווים.
נכון וזה בגודל. אין על אין! נכון.
אז מה שבעצם יצא כאן זה ש.
העמודה הראשונה.
Output. תהיה פשוט מכפלה של וי אחד בכל אחד מהם.
מה שבעצם יוצא. אז אם זה?
אכן חד. חד MS נכון?
אז עכשיו העמודה הראשונה כאן נכון?
זה מה זה בעצם V1 כפול? השורה הראשונה?
כן, זה בעצם הקואורדינציה הראשונה קואורדינציה. השנייה זה V1 כפול השורה השנייה והאחד כפול השורה השלישית וכן הלאה וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
אה. סליחה פה, אה רגע, עשיתי כן, אוקיי, זה מה ט נכון תודה.
הפכתי פה את אה? כן צודק.
הפכתי את הסדר, הייתי צריך לכפול מהצד השני. זה מה שבלט פה.
אוקיי, כתוב שעשינו את זה. סליחה על הטעות. אז אוקיי, אבל צריך לכפול מהצד השני.
ואז זה בסדר ככה. זה.
וי כפול אין. כן סליחה, תמיד צריך להיות בצד השני.
אז וי כפול M זה? אוקיי, זה נשמע יותר הגיוני ועכשיו זה אלה בדיוק.
כן, כדי לקבל פה סליחה כדי לקבל פה את העמודה הראשונה.
למה היא יוצאת? יוצאת. המקדם הזה כפול V1 ועוד.
המקדם הזה כפול V2 ועוד. המקדם הזה כפול V3 עדיין אחד VM נכון?
לכן מה אני צריך שיסתכם לאחד העמודות בדיוק?
אז תחת המוטציה הזאת המצח שהמידות הסתכמו לאחד? סכום שווה 1.
בסדר, אז פשוט אני מחשב את המטריצה של המכפלות השכליות.
אני עושה soft max פר עמודה. אם אני אעשה או פר שורה, אם אני עושה את זה ההפך.
אבל אז גם צריך להפוך את המכפלה של האיקס דרייב, ואני מקבל סט של וקטור מצב שהוא מטריצה חדשה של וקטורים.
נכון שהם וקטור? מה אתה? לא הרבה יותר באיקס כי איקס הוא בגודל של DB על אין.
על כן אין כלל. פשוט הפכתי באחרון את הסדר שלהם אצל.
כן. אוקיי, כן. קצת הורס את כל המודל הזה.
בדיוק זה מטריצה של זדים?
כן. אז זה שווה? אוקיי.
אחלה של זה לצד עם האלה אנחנו גם לפעמים מסמנים את זה פשוט קטן שם.
קיו קאווי בסדר, זה סימון מקובל.
יפה, אבל בעצם הצורה השימושית יותר היא לא להשתמש פשוט בקומבינציה אחת.
כי לפעמים יכול להיות שאנחנו רוצים לצרכים שונים לחבר יחד מילים אחרות.
אוקיי, אז למשל לצרכים תחביריים. תומי כדוגמת Breakfast או Something, זה אומר זה בעצם נגיד פועל ומושא ישיר.
נכון תחבירית, אם נסתכל רק על התחביר זה to make love.
כן, אז Dogs Breakfast הוא מושא ישיר. מצד שני, ברור שזה מבחינת הוא גם ביטוי.
אז אולי אני רוצה לייצג פה כמה מימדים שונים. מה שגם מגלים זה כשלומדים את זה שחלק מהתפקיד של העץ זה גם כאילו חלק מהעצם מיותרים בדיעבד.
ודבר מאוד מעניין שכאילו אם אתם מקטינים את מספר ההדס, תכף אני אסביר בדיוק מה זה.
ואם אתם מקטינים את מספר ההדס אתם מקבלים ביצועים פחות טובים.
אבל אם אתם מאמנים עם הרבה הדס ואז בדיעבד בודקים איזה מהעץ באמת עושים עבודה ואיזה מהם כמעט לא נלקחים בחשבון,
אתם מגלים שאתם יכולים לזרוק לא מעט מהם, אבל מראש אתם לא ידעתם.
מה זה להיות בקבוצה? כן, בדיוק. בעצם אין ביניהם שום.
בעצם. תכף אני אגיד על זה מילה. זו שאלה טובה. תכף אני אגיד על זה מילה.
כן, כשאתה מאמן מספר כלשהו של עצמך לתפקיד הזה לא כל כך קורה אותו דבר.
רק אחרי זה בדיוק. כן, כשאתה מוריד מספר אצבעות זה פוגע בביצועים.
אבל אם אתה בדיעבד בודק איזה מהם עושים עבודה ואיזה לא על ידי כל מיני מדדים סטטיסטיים, אז אתה יכול להוריד חלק מהם בלי כמעט סיבה.
בקיצור. אוקיי, אז אז מה זה multi has multi head?
זה רעיון מאוד דומה, רק שעכשיו אני בעצם יש לי כמה מטריצות כאלה.
כמה דבליו קיו עם כמה דבליו, כמה זה אבל אהובים.
כל שלישייה כזאת מכפילה את סטייל פוטין.
קרן את אותו איקס מכפילה אותה ואז אני מקבל בעצם זדים.
אז מטריצת הזאת אם זה ה head הזה head אחד H2 מהדהד h ואז אני כופה את זה בעוד מטריצה כדי לקבל שהיא בעצם איזשהו טרנספורמציה לינארית של השירשור שלהם.
בסדר שגם היא נלמדת בכל. בעצם אני לשרשר אותם אחד לשני למין וקטור ארוך ארוך כזה.
כאילו כל אחד כן במקרה כאן זה בעצם מטריצה.
אז אני משרשרת זה למין מטריצה ארוכה יש לי אולי כאן לא.
אבל כן. מה, כאילו כל אחד מהדברים האלה הוא בעצם מטריצה כזאת.
אוקיי, אז בעצם יש לך סט ראשון של סט אחד, צד שני של זה לחצי הדם, צד שלישי של משרשרת כולם אחד לשני.
מה לעשות? טוב. לא כאילו אתה משרשרת אותם ככה.
כן? פה יש זד אחד שתיים נגיד.
ופה יש עוד שלוש. אבל כל אחד מהם נוצר עם מטריצות אחרות.
כן, עם דאבל קיי, דאבל ודאבל יגיעו אחרים.
אז גם למצוא זד עם אחרים. אבל עכשיו קיבלת לכל מילה ייצוג פי שלוש באורך שלו.
נגיד אם היה לך שלושה Heads אתה רוצה להחזיר את זה חזרה לאותו מימד.
אתה לומד איזה שהיא מטריצה שהיא דואגת לה, גם עושה טרנספורמציה וגם דואגת למימדי טרנספורמציה לינארית.
כן. שוב, אין כאן ולא דבר שאפשר כל כך להצדיק אותו כמו הרבה דברים כאן.
סתם אומר הגדלת את המימד איך שהוא רוצה לכווץ את זה בחזרה.
איך אתה מכווץ? הדרך הכי פשוטה זה הפרופורציה לינארית. זה מה שאתה עושה אם הם היו עושים את זה בדרך אחרת, האם זה עובד יותר טוב?
אולי הם ניסו? אולי הם עשו, אתה יודע. אין אין אין הצדקה במאמר.
למה דווקא ככה? אוהבת אותך וסוויפט. אוקיי, יפה, אז אנחנו מתקדמים, אז יש לנו כמה.
אז אנחנו כבר יודעים איך זה עובד בעצם.
כן, אם נחזור לשכבת סוף Attention, אנחנו כבר בערך מבינים איך הדבר הזה עובד.
נכון, יש לנו את האיקסים, יש לנו את מטריצת דאבל עכשיו דאבל דאבל קיי.
הם מייצרות לנו, כל אחד מהם סט של זדים.
אם יש כמה Heads, אני משרשרת אותם ביחד ומוריד להם חזרה את המימד.
אחרי זה אני מכניס את זה לאיזה רשת. פיט פור עוד קטנה, אבל בעצם יש עוד אלמנט אחד.
אגב, כל הדברים האלה למדתם פחות או יותר כן, אוקיי, אחלה סתם יש לכם חזרה.
עוד דבר אחד שאני לא אכנס אליו לעומק, אבל מסתבר הוא חשוב בשביל היציבות של האימון.
זה מה שנקרא רזי ג'ול Connection learn. נורמלי זה השם שבטח בקורס deep learning.
זה נושא מאוד טכני. כן, שהוא לא ספציפי דווקא ל Transformer משתמשים בו בהרבה והרבה מאוד סוגי רשתות.
כן, מה שבגדול מצאו שם מכל מיני סיבות שלא קשורות ספציפית של הטרנספורמר ים,
אלא עקרונות כלליים שמי שמתעניין לקרוא יכול לקרוא כאן את המאמר שמציג את הרעיון הזה שבא ואחרים מ 2006.
מה שעושים זה בעצם לוקחים, וכל פעם שמפעילים סנדלר כן, נגיד Fit forward אמר או אסף את tension multi head פטנט של וכן הלאה.
אז בעצם לוקחים את העודפות של זה. מוסיפים לזה את איקס כאילו את המקור בעצם שלא עובר דרך הרשת.
בגלל זה קוראים לזה רזין שהוא כאילו זה עוקף אותה ואז עושים איזושהי נורמליזציה.
כאמור, לא זה פרט יותר ממשי. כן, וזו הסיבה שכשאתם עכשיו אנחנו מגיעים באמצע הטרנספורמר לארכיטקטורה שלמה.
אז אתם רואים? זה קודר מה שכתוב כאן. אז מה שאומר זה אין שכבות?
כן, כי זה טקסט אחד על השני. הרבה פעמים שמים כמה שכבות, אין שכבות שכל אחד מהם היא מולטי head tension.
אז הנורמליזציה הזאת, וזו גם הסיבה שאתם תראו חץ כזה.
הסיבה לחץ הזה זה בגלל שזה באמת איקס ועוד סולר של X שמחברים אותה.
אז בגלל זה זה עד קלאס עדן? נועם מסמנים את זה.
זה כאמור משהו שלצרכן הוא לא נורא חשוב, אבל כן חשוב עם Practice ואז אתה output הזה, אתם מזינים לפי איזשהו פיתחו,
נפגשו ועושים את היעד פלוס now בסדר וככה עושים את זה סקאט אחד על גבי השני ומייצרים בעצם את אינדקס של כל אחד מהם input vector.
יפה אז זה הארכיטקטורה של הטרנספורמר בהיי.
לזה אנחנו כמובן ניכנס לפרטים של כל החתיכות ונבין מה הם אומרים, אבל זה ארכיטקטורה.
היי לב, מה שדיברנו עד עכשיו זה שכבה אחת מתוך האפ code.
כן, שכפי שאתם רואים באופן כללי יכולות להיות הן שכבות.
כן מספר כל 3 שכבות טקסט אחד על גבי השני.
מה שהרשת הזאת עושה רשת של Cover כמו תמיד בנקודת דיקור דר Models היא מזינה רשת אחרת שהיא
הדיקור DIR שיש לה ארכיטקטורה דומה אבל גם קצת שונה בכמה נקודות חשובות שתכף נדבר עליהם.
אבל סך הכל קונספטואלית דומה הרשת.
הדיקור קודר, מקבלת בדיוק מה שדיברנו בהקשר של הרמן מקבלת מצד אחד את האאוטפיט של האינקובטור.
כן, את הסלפי Tension output זאת וסט, כלומר וקטור לכל אחד מהם איקסים שהכנסנו כאן כמספר כמספר התקנים שהכנסנו.
נקבל וקטורים שיוצאים קודם ובנוסף ייצוג של איקס.
כן, היא תקבל גם תפריט פיקס ומה שהרשת הזאת תוציא זה בסוף soft max.
שמייצג בדיוק מה שדיברנו קודם, שהוא בעצם Language.
למעשה, הביקורת אולי כמו The Model שמקבל בשמה.
שמודל הסטנדרטי מקבל חוץ מ וואי אחד את Y מנוסחת, כלומר איקסים מקבל גם את X או במקרה שלנו את output שלה.
אני כותב עוד נקודה שכבר חשוב לי בשלב הזה.
לציין זה שהרשת הזאת היא לא הרנן.
בעצם היא לא הרנן. לא, לא יהיה כאן בעצם מקרה שבו גרף החישוב תלוי באורך הסיכויים.
זה לא יקרה כאן. אלא יש שם אורך קבוע של input order ולדיכוי דרגת המעשה.
אבל תכף נדבר על התיקון בו יש לנו איזשהו אורך קבוע, מספר איתותים קבוע.
אתם יכולים לשאול טוב מה קורה עם INPUT שאני קצר מדי, אז מוסיפים איזה padding.
יש איזשהו תוכן מיוחד? מה קורה אם הוא ארוך מדי? כל מה שזז.
מי שלא יודע מי יודעה. אז כן, נקווה שלא ניתקל כרגע.
כן, אחרי זה אולי נדבר מה באמת עושים אבל כרגע לא נתמך.
לא נתמך. Error message. בסדר, אז אנחנו יכולים לתרגם באורך מסוים וזה fed forward network.
כן, אין כאן שום דבר של חישוב שחוזר חזרה פנימה לתוך הרשת ועושה עוד חישוביות, חישוביות, חישוב על גבי עצמו.
מה שכן, זה שיש כאן רשת מאוד עמוקה. כן, הרבה שכבות של Corner.
כל אחת מתוכם יש לה מבנה פנימי, אחרי זה מוזרה ודי קודר.
גם פה יש הרבה שכבות. בקיצור רשת גדולה אבל היא לא וקוהרנטית וגודל ה input הוא קבוע.
יפה. זה דבר.
כמו כן טוב. אז אולי לפני שאני מגיע לזה שניה אחת אני דווקא רוצה לקפוץ לכאן.
לגבי הנקודה של הפוזיציה. נכון? אז דיברנו על זה שבעצם הטרנספורמר, כפי שהצגתי אותו, הוא לגמרי סימטרי.
הוא בעצם סימטרי. לגבי המיקום הוא גם האמת סימטרי זה התכוונתי לציין קודם.
אני אציין אותו עכשיו. הוא גם סימטרי מבחינת העץ. זאת אומרת אין לאט.
יורית ה heads הם זהים אחד לשני בתחילת האימון.
כן. הדבר היחידי שגורם לזה שהרשת לא תלמד את אותו ההד עוד פעם ועוד פעם ועוד פעם תלמד בדיוק את אותה מטריצות.
זה בגלל שאנחנו מוסיפים רעש. אנחנו מוסיפים איזה רנדום היא משלי. זה ישן בהתחלה על המטריצות האלה שגורם לכל אחד לקבל כיוון קצת אחר.
אוקיי, והרשת בדרך כלל לא עקרונית יכולה להתכנס למצב שכל העצב זהים אבל אפקטיבית.
היא לא עושה את זה בגלל תנאי התחלה שונים ובגלל שכל זה גם Sub אופטימלי לעשות את זה.
מטבע הדברים אין, אין טעם שכל אדי עושה בדיוק את אותו חישוב לבזבז.
מבזבז את ה אקספרסיביות הנוספת של הרשת, אבל זה הדבר היחידי.
כנל לגבי האינפוט. אם עכשיו האינפוט, אם זה בעיה יותר חמורה כן, כי באים פרטים.
זה לא רק סימטריה ביחס ל טריינינג. נכון? בתחילת טריינינג כל האינפוט אם זהים.
אלא זה גם נשאר ככה. בעצם אין שום מקום עד כה שדיברנו עליו נכון בתוך הסרט פטנט שבו לוקחים בחשבון את זה שזה machine thinking ולא thinking.
הדרך שעושים את זה זה באמצעות position. הלימודים. בגדול position זה רעיון שאומר ככה אומר אני בעצם מלבד הפרמטרים שדיברנו עליהם עכשיו.
של הסלפי tension שזה הדאבל קיו laws ואם זה מולטי head אז דאבלין UI גם.
דבליו, דבליו, דבליו VI לכל שכבה ברשת לכל tension head פלוס הפרמטרים של הפיד forward Network.
חוץ מכל הדברים האלה, גם לכל מיקום.
אוקיי, הטרנספורמר יש בעצם including של המיקום הזה.
בהתחלה זה פשוט וקטור רנדומלי, אבל זה פרמטר.
זה לאו פרמטר של המודל. ובעצם מה שאנחנו אומרים זה שלמרות שכל המיקומים הם סימטריים.
אנחנו מצפים מהמודל לאט לאט לקודד את האינפורמציה הרלוונטית שיש במיקום הזה, המסוים שלו.
תוך כדי הלמידה, יחד עם הלמידה של כל אחד מהדברים האחרים,
יחד עם זה שהוא לומד איזה מילים צריכות להסתכל על איזה מילים הוא גם צריך ללמוד איך מקודדים בכלל את המיקום של המילים כן או איזה מידע יש?
מה זה בדיוק אומר אם ברק טס? אנחנו לא בדיוק יודעים איך הרשת הזאת עובדת,
אבל כאילו הרעיון הבסיסי הוא אנחנו מוסיפים לרשת עוד אקספרסיביות שתוכל לקודד את זה כמו יחס לא תעשה עם אקספרסיביות הנוספת הזאת.
מקווים שיהיה בסדר. כן.
אז אוקיי, אז במילים אחרות הפוזיציה בזה זה לכל אינדקס ב input יש לנו עוד וקטור שמייצג זה בהתחלה בתחילת האימון או פשוט רנטון וקטור אבל הוא נלמד.
הרנו וקטור הזה הוא פשוט מתווסף האינפוט. אם כן אז אם נגיד האינפוט בלינק שלי הם סקיפ, גם מה שלמדנו אז יהיה לי עכשיו את נגיד המשפט שלי הוא.
היי went! To sleep.
אוקיי, אז כל אחד מאלה יקבל איזשהו פקטור. כן, באים פה עם Padding.
שזה בדרך כלל log. לא עושים את זה קבוע. גם את זה עושים כאיזושהי שכבה נגמרת.
זה לא חייב להיות. זה גם יכול להיות script גרא ממה שאתם רוצים.
אז כל אחד מאלה ממופה לווקטור. אוקיי.
ועכשיו איזה שני הווקטורים פה זהים? אה? סליחה, זה לא טוב.
התכוונתי להגיד משהו. אוקיי. אוקיי.
אז איזה שני וקטורים זהים? בדיוק?
אז הווקטור הזה שווה לווקטור הזה? בדיוק מה שעובר את הסימטריה.
כי יש לי עוד וקטור שהוא פוזישן עלי בדיוק מספר אחד.
שמתווסף לאיי פוזישן. אבל את המספר 2 שהתווסף לווינדוס יש שם.
מספר שלוש טור וכן הלאה. אלה וקטורים שמשותפים לכל התוכניות שיש.
שאנחנו נעבוד עליהם שהם במקום שלישי.
או חמישי או אתם ספציפיים לאינדקס על פני כל ה input ואז אנחנו נוסיף לזה את וקטור מספר 3 ולזה את וקטור מספר 5 וזה מה שישבור את הסימטריה.
אז הם משתנים ואז הם משתנים ואז יש להם לפחות עקרונית כן אפשרות להיות שם.
אז אני לב. זה האוצר.
אתה יכול לחשוב על זה, כמה זה פשוט יכול לסדר אותם כמוצרי קצה.
אבל דה פקטו מה שזה. זה פשוט וקטור לכל אינדקס.
התרגיל הזה. זה פשוט חלק מגרף החישוב.
נכון? תחשוב על עכשיו על גרף החישוב שמתאים לנקודה או לא, לא משנה אלף למדי קודר זה יותר רעיון.
אז גרף החישוב יגיד נגיד הזנת איליו את I went to wait.
אז בעצם מה שגרף החישוב יגיד זה שיש לך בעצם.
איזה שהם פרמטרים. אחד לכל אחד.
האורך המקסימלי של INPUT שאתה מרשה. אחד עד 200 וכל אחד מהם זה פשוט איזשהו לא קאפ table כזה.
כן, זה פשוט חלק מהפרמטרים של המודל שהם נכנסים לתוך החישוב.
אז כשאתה עושה backup Again אתה גם מגיע אליהם. אז בעצם כל מילה.
האינפוט שלה שנכנס לרשת מורכב מחיבור של שני וקטורים.
וקטור אחד תלוי רק במיקום ולא תלוי במילה. כלומר בכל המשפטים שיש תכניס תמיד המילה באינדקס שלוש.
המילה השלישית פסיק תקבל את אותו אם בדיוק שם את זה.
לי זה יותר ברור. אז הכל תקין.
אם כן אז. אוקיי, ועכשיו כל אחד מאלה זה פקטור.
אז זה הפקטור של המילה to. הוא אותו דבר כמו הווקטור הלבן כאן, אבל זה הווקטור של i3 שווה אחד.
זה המסר של הג'וקר שתיים בקיצור. וכן הלאה.
עכשיו אתה תוסיף אליו שני וקטורים שונים. אם עכשיו יהיה לך משפט אחר, נגיד המשפט.
לא נהגו פעם. העגור?
האהוב. אז כדי לחשב אותו אתה תצטרך לקחת מזה את הווקטור שמכאיב לגוף.
לחבר אותו עם הווקטור הזה, נכון?
איתו אתה צריך לקחת את הווקטור הזה שהוא גם הפקטור הזה ולחבר אותו עם וקטור שתיים.
אבל בשביל טאו הווקטור הזה מחבר אותו עם הווקטור שלו.
בסדר. עוד שאלות.
אוקיי. אז זה בעצם דבר הכביש ששובר את הסימטריה באופן מפתיע.
ובאמת עשינו. מכיוון שפעם ראשונה שקראנו את המאמר הזה בסמינר אצלי הוא יצא בקבוצה.
אני לא האמנתי שבעצם זה מה שהם עושים. זה נשמע לי מאוד מאוד משונה.
אז ביקשתי מסטודנט שלי שיעשה את הדבר הבא ייקח בעצם נגיד רק עם פה צמצם בגודל.
נגיד יתרגם, לא זוכר באיזה שפה, לאיזו שפה זה היה. בוא נגיד אנגלית לגרמנית ייקח נגיד משפטים באורך 17 באנגלית.
ייקח איזושהי פר מוטציה קבועה עליהם.
כן ירבה אותם באיזושהי צורה אבל קבועה את כל המשפטים ועכשיו ילמד מודל תרגום מאפס שיוצא מכרמי English לגרמנית או מ non peer מיוחדת English לגרמנית.
ורציתי לפתח את הפרפורמנס. מה דעתכם?
זה זהה לגמרי. כן, פשוט לא אכפת לו. זה שאני מדבר על כמה זה חמור כן, כי זה לא מבחינתי בדיוק.
זה לגמרי סימטרי. יש דרכים אחרות לקודד את פוזישן, קודים שהם פיקס ואז זה כן טיפה משפיע.
אבל אם זה בצורה שפשוט זה ווקטורים נלמדים.
חלום. אין שום הבדל. אז זה באמת כך.
הם לא מרבים טוב. יפה.
עוד כמה הערות לגבי הדקות הראשון המוצלח.
טוב, אולי אני אדבר עוד על הדיקור. דר וקסום.
אני אחזור על זה בתחילת שבוע הבא. הדי קודר.
יש לו מבנה מאוד דומה לזה של קולטר, אבל יש כמה דברים קצת שונים.
דבר אחד זה שהוא משתמש בעצם ב מכניזם מאוד דומה לסלפי tension אבל קצת שונה שנקרא cross attention.
מה הרעיון בקרוס attention? אז בעצם אם תשימו לב אתם תראו שבא עם ב output כאילו בדיקות ציד הווקטורים כן האיקסים נכנסים בהתחלה באמת לתוך מולטי הד.
התנשקנו. גם כאן כתוב mask ששיעור הבא נדבר.
מה זה בדיוק אומר המשחק הזה?
אבל בגדול אם נכנסים למולטי tension עוברים את טוסון ואז הם נכנסים לעוד מולטי הדת Engine שמקבל גם את הווקטורים של הפרי FX שמייצגים את הפרי FX,
אבל גם את הווקטורים. קודם כול, הדברים צריכים לקחת בחשבון גם את הפרי וגם את Core, גם את סרפנד וגם את קודם.
אז עכשיו אנחנו צריכים בעצם לעשות את tension על set שהוא לא באותו גודל.
כן זה כאילו יש לי אין וקטורים מהדקה Other הם וקטורים, מעין counter ואני צריך לתרגם אותם ל n וקטורים חדשים של הדי קורבר.
אז מסתבר שהשינוי הוא מאוד קטן. כן cross.
הטלפון פשוט אומר שזה פשוט לעשות את להפעיל את אותו המנגנון.
רק שעכשיו מגיע מאוסף אחד של וקטורים.
כן, הוא בעצם עכשיו נוצר מאיזשהו איקס מסוים והכי נוצר מאיזשהו איקס תג אחר, שבמקרה שלנו הוא פשוט שרשור של איקס ושל עוד וקטורים שהגיעו Order.
אז במילים אחרות, אם קודם היה לנו מטריצה נכון Null שאומר לכל קווירי וקי.
מה המכפלה השכלית ביניהם ואז עשינו על זה Soft Max. במקום זה עכשיו מה שאנחנו נעשה זה כל אחד מהם Values.
נכון, כל אחת מהווה. בעצם הערך שלו.
ייקבע כאיזושהי קומבינציה קמורה גם של הווקטורים, מעין codes וגם של הווקטורים מהדקה Order.
המקדמים של הווקטורים האלה נקבעים גם לפי הווקטורים שלהם קוטר וגם לפי הווקטורים של הניקוד.
על כן אז במילים אחרות לא יהיה לי סט אחד של קווירי.
אז כן שזה יהיה לי קווירי. וקטור אחד לכל מילה.
בדיקה אורדר כל מילה שאני רוצה לפלוט. אבל הכיס שלי עכשיו יהיה בגודל n פלוס m כי גם זה צריך לקחת כי גם זה נותן מקדמים פרטים של האינקובטור.
כן, יכול להיות שזה קצת קשה לעשות את זה בסוף השיעור אחרי שלוש שעות.
אז בוא נתחיל מהנקודה הזאת בפעם הבאה יש טענות לדבר על הדיקור ואז נעבור קצת להיוולד.
יועציה של נשים Translation ומשם נתחיל לדבר על language large language, מה שנקרא.
אז נתראה שבוע הבא. נעשה מעניין עוד יותר.
שר התחבורה ישראל. כץ אפשר וצריך.
קצת. יותר לפטר את הרב הגדול.
בעולם השלב הראשון בסך הכל גם בסדר.
יש נגיד למשל שסך הכל החשבון של נאמנויות היום נשלטות עצומות.
בסמארט. יש די הרבה עבודה לנסות לשפר את הצעת החוק החדשה, כפי שהנשיא.
יש איחוד בין אוגוסט 2016, שהתחיל להיות מאוד מקורב יחסית כל כך הרבה לחצי שנה, אבל יש גם פחות לחץ על לנסות ולייצר נוסח מסורתי.
בסדר, אבל. תראה, הטרנספורמר הוא עדיין השיטה הכי פופולרית, אבל השאלה גם מה אתה עושה עם הקונצפט.
זאת אומרת, יש דרכים נגיד אז יותר יעילות לאמן או יש דרכים לעשות לו מה שנקרא סטילס להזמין אותו כן כן או יש, אתה יודע, אני מתעסק בזה במחקר שלנו.
רועי ברוקס, חבר סגל אצלנו, אז הוא כנראה יכיר את הטכניקות הכי עכשיו אולי אתה יכול לכתוב משהו לפני דלתך שמשהו הולך לעשות את זה?
זו בטח יש לך תשובה יותר טובה. בסדר, פספסתי כל כך מעט את החשיבה שלך.
אוקיי, אז. Cave [INAUDIBLE] הם מאוד.
הם מאוד דומים, אבל בעצם רואים בעיקר את ההבדל ביניהם ב cross temp.
כשיש לך מספר שהמשקל. ואז בעצם מספר הקורס שאני חושבת זה כמספר פרטים ומספר הכיס זה מספר, אבל סך הכל יש להם תפקיד מאוד דומה.
כנראה שהם מוכפלים אחד בשני בזוגות.
אבל זה בעצם הערכים, כי בעצם המכפלה של דבליו וי כפולות X זה בעצם הערכים שלהם את עושה הצירוף כאמור, זאת לא עושה צירוף כמו ישירות של האיקסים.
את עושה צירוף כמות של המכפלה של דם לפיו אז יש כאן תפקיד קצת אחר שהתפקיד שלהם זה איכשהו להטיל את.
את האיקסים במימד הפנימי שבו פד נעשה לפי tension ואז על זה עושים.
צריך לזכור. אפשר לחשוב קצת אחרת כשאתה רואה שבנו שחר נמצא מחוץ והסוף בסיפור.
אז יש איזשהו קשר? כן.
אז הרעיון הוא בעצם. לבן קוראים Valley.
זה בגלל שבסוף הזג. כלומר האוטובוס של הספר הוא קומדיה נורא.
כן, אז כאילו זה, אבל זה דבר שיוצא החוצה להיות בז, כי זכור לי כי בעצם כשחושבים על זה, זה שכל מבנה בעצם כדי לפשט מקדם.